[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir
the lowest day sunday what's going on my
check my check and all that good stuff
what's going on gerald mack i see you
bright and early what's going on i saw
the video salute salute what's going on
we gotta keep it respectful of course of
course
eric lebron was going on
talk to me ghost fixer what's up what's
going on
lydian master what's up man what's going
on red hood the red hood is in here you
know
you're over here early chris 713 what's
up
facebook i see you daniel mcgee what's
going on what's going on no doubt no
doubt
phantom knife move what's up the dawn
excuse me ladies and gentlemen i
appreciate you
hello lords what a great day the lord
has given us no doubt the church what's
going on i had to get a building talk to
the people
what's going on guys
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
a lot what's up what's up what's going
on so yeah we gonna wait for the
legendary mr jazz quarter to get in the
realm
talk to y'all all that good stuff have
some fun fun topics and all that so i
will be back see y'all
[Music]
[Music]
let me get the dawn now since all this
you know might not be here donald taco 2
super chat what's the topic for the game
of the year xenoblade chronicles
or red game
got your flag down
two is good people like one better than
two
three you know a lot of potential but um
there's this little game called elder
ring oh sound don't heard of it
a lot of contenders but one
main one has been holding the test but i
had to get done right we will be back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all are messed up and turn me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't heard a boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
and turn me to an animal and headless be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
[Applause]
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my
vocals on twitter but i'm anti-social
love my city but i'm still by coastal i
got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so
i know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to
um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals but i'm
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line y'all this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to
advancedg.com use code iron lord on the
checkout this is something i use all the
time got to support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
which flies
[Music]
imma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be meto i know it's
my destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
stevo
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
and
we are live i believe levels levels and
all that we check talk real quick let me
see some levels
hello
i want to point to you guys out the
attic was here
this wasn't an attic thing you know it's
funny attic be here every day
every week 30 40 minutes
but the one week he's not everyone act
like it's the rule but not the exception
you're sitting here captain right if a
cat could pop out this guy a cat a cat
would slide down on his head like
this
[Laughter]
and we are live chat layoff attic stop
it welcome to the highlands podcast llc
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 262. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day i would be
excited about our special guest but we
don't know where he is chat uh highlight
just called it uh i know he was awake i
said i i i want you guys to go on
twitter
tag jazz get this where you at
yeah put where you had chase gordon
hashtag iop and then put mad shrimp
emojis because you probably had too much
shrimp last night because you know i
just did
that's what i want you guys to do i want
you to go on twitter freedom kenneth
and then say where you at hashtag iop
there you go hit him up hit him that's
the whole
[Laughter]
so until our special guest arrives we
got a xbox sales japan fidelity super
resolution 2 on xbox
god of war ragnarok potentially imminent
and xbox long-term strategy to discuss
so we're going to get right into it so
let's introduce those four horsemen of
gateway three uh oh okay
another one
shout out to the lord son get in there
okay i believe you're up at pr doing
this thing you know how he do shout out
to saul send some love this off kingdom
[Laughter]
how are we telling people
to solve on vacation we gotta settle up
with him
he said he ain't saying no send no love
to king last year
how your man did me dirty let's go
dude was ready i was ready i know you
was i had a whole i know you know i had
a whole scenario see he doesn't tell you
he always calls me at 7 30. i mean
people call you king croc in the in the
chat no that's my name though that's my
name so what i got favorite shut up
ziggy
he's supposed to call me at 12 30. can't
get up
yeah bucking out on the phone right here
so i had something set up i had a pool
size situation i had a little floatie
that matched my crotch oh i had i was
gonna have my drink in my hand and y'all
guys were gonna get i had that for a
headset charge eight i know them too
i know i'm too well he's gonna do
something to annoy me he stole he stole
he stole my glory he stole my glory
you was on vacation i can't wake up
come in on vacation with a laptop in the
corner in the airport
guys how y'all doing he get a chance to
do his moment right
i don't get a chance to do my croc team
moment you need to rest that weekend
that's what i felt we made a judgment
call did you this is some bs here
anyway oh my co-host with the compose
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man lord addict of the attic show
fantastic
obsidian interview by the way how we
doing sir
doing pretty good yeah definitely uh you
guys go check out the uh interview i did
i did an interview with
megan she came on iop a while back
megan stark she she came on a she she's
a senior writer of obsidian i was going
to get to that
she came on iop it was probably about a
year and a half ago
so i brought her back on the attic show
you we went a little bit more detail on
what she does from a day to day as an
obsidian senior writer uh so i
definitely apologize uh the promotion of
that show was a little bit off normally
i promoted the day
like early that day or or the night
before but uh it was just it was just so
chaotic and uh frankly i didn't know
she's coming to the last minute so uh
you know i got that took care of though
and i hope you guys enjoyed it you know
uh this week we'll go back to regular i
i there will be like a double thing
going on wednesday because i'll have two
things going on wednesday instead of
just one i'm gonna have an interview and
we'll have the attic show wednesday oh
okay we got the double feature no doubt
no doubt look we we should be keeping it
low what we got right we ain't exporting
that just yet for that
we i could say um
uh project man i have a hard time
pronouncing it
it's the fan of brigade i think that's
how you pronounce it yeah yeah the
uppercut
yeah so i have uh phantom brigade
interview uh now i'm not gonna say the
names of the people because uh i gotta
make sure that they actually uh
you know they're confirmed first but
we'll be having uh we'll be interviewing
them about you know the game in general
and then we'll be having that attic show
right before because i i didn't i did
get a lot of feedback saying like look
we we love your show but we don't care
about these interviews
okay yeah i'ma separate the two entities
because and another point like i got
hustle and dirt usually rotating and
like let's be real here like you know
they might care about some of the games
but i ain't trying to make people feel
like they obligated to do what you do so
it's just i might as well just go ahead
and separate out you want to get a
couple of super chats before we move on
the king's intro i can help out
we got a
member chat uh we got a one drink dutch
with the one year remember chat said
lord's day respect no doubt we got the
two dollar superchat from kellyanne
brown you thought solve was going to
stop missing days oh oh oh attendance
call out oh you got a five dollar
sweeped out from dollar otaku you don't
rock with the crocs
no no
say it right we don't rock with the
crocs more i need more chats like this
this is what i'm talking about he turns
his camera
you don't rock with the cracks that's
why your feet hurt
he said with the bad bunions you got
there he said yeezy foam runners only
king i got that i i rock easy boost
don't come at me sideways bro
so if you're rocking easies why are you
why are you no no you understand listen
what alert
i got i got to say this man uh-oh but go
ahead keep reading
king you going to be an out of be on
outriders tuesday if so what's your
gamer time
king david otw bro stop playing with me
stop acting like you wouldn't ask me you
better add listen outriders is a goat i
already paid for that soon as i saw the
trailer go straight to the uninstall
bucket oh damn oh that's nice let me do
that with your final fantasy
yeah that's cool y'all being petty with
each other
that's the last time you heard see see i
have a revolution going on about my
final because this is the last time you
saw a hashtag say bring out writers
anywhere everywhere
okay i can tell you this it's gonna be
number one y'all's gonna fall in the
number 200.
we really doing the deal
on tuesday what's gonna be the most
talked about we outside
did king snatch up the cowboy crocs did
you cop
oh no see your mouth
i'm gonna leave that to you because you
like to hide yo yo your ankles oh my
lord
[Laughter]
wait a second here hold on i feel like
there's something wrong oh man
[Music]
i want you guys to run anytime you see
he wants you to hide your ankles so be
careful
bob's don't forget that he'll flash
those ankles any day of the week he he
ride it he ride it ankle watch salute
jeff gruff said all my hobies have great
what he said he said all his homies got
great ankles his ankles is outside
that's right you gotta have the cracks
like how your ankles are these streets
see yo you got no dudes with bad ankles
can't wear crocs do
you want to deal with those little
anyway you caught up with a super chat
hashtag watch those ankles a kid no ashy
ankles for sure oh you know dudes is out
here with the kevin durant oh lord get
the crocodile
those are terrible
anyway
we caught up with chancellor hey we got
a a member chat for 15 months for peta
kelly tuller 9 000 i don't know
let's go i have a great show uh have a
great show thank you sir
absolutely you already know and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer oh the prophet
of xbox king of
don't do that don't do that don't cry i
don't want to hear that though it's your
fear i don't ain't nobody ever going to
call you kill a criminal nobody call you
kill a [ __ ] right now man you're going
to respect my guy
that sounds good sounds like that sounds
like one of those like generic origin
villains
is is it is a batman villain killer croc
we're going to respect the suicide squad
kill the crocs in the building let's get
it okay let's give it a try
who demands nothing less than their
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir we
doing fantastic sorry i wasn't with you
guys last week uh due to uh sabotage um
i couldn't join you guys but i i did
miss you i watched your show in his
entirety and and i gotta say
you guys did a fantastic job i
appreciate you i i do i thought
even though i wasn't there and i had
magic you know how it is you know how
you got fomo you watching the show and
you're doing your own ad libs from
inside cause this is what you would have
said you're like man this is the part i
was like yo these dudes have so much fun
um i miss my homies oh salute
we do you do your thing man and i always
like when you get a chance to rest real
talk though like you one of the hardest
workers you're always here all the time
you never take off like be added be like
yo can we get a date
oh my god all right so
shout out to uh cyberpunk um it came out
or the debut um it came out man it just
released it's playing beautiful it's
still got some glitches though i'm doing
this one joint and i see a whole npc a
random npc start walking into a wall to
try to go inside this guy house
so i said hey i'm going to try it too
i said maybe this mpc is on something
he wasn't he wasn't um
it reminds me of um deus ex um
just a little bit like because deus ex
world was a little more more confined
this world is a little bit more dense a
little bit more open yes stuff for you
to see
it's
it's very ambitious so far in my early
going ons with the game so
uh i do appreciate all the hard work
that went into it now i do see some
visual stuff but the game is just so
vast to be honest with you there's so
much stuff going on into it i really
think they should have just released it
like two years later because it needed
whatever polish type
um
playing destiny i did my first i'm not
finished with my dungeon
right i'm not finished with that because
uh sinister ran off chris uh did some
sucker bs oh
um you know they threw monkey in at the
last part
yeah me and monkey's getting down in it
so it's like okay so we doing the
dungeon thing we're having a math fun
doing it and
the last part the last boss because i
thought that one boss that you got to
was the boss right there no it's not
it's three boys yeah yeah yeah
right so we i'm up to the last post i
got the checkpoint for the last boss i'm
not the last with the bells yeah with
the belts yeah okay in and out worlds
yeah and stage things with the rays yeah
it's dope i like i like that aspect of
it they gave you something different
they still working and remember attic
where it was uh we we didn't like the
leviathan because it looked like the
third floor in the apartment
but they actually went back to the
leviathan and fleshed out some other
things in it so i think it's cool um
a lot of the weapons that you get from
it i'm learning different things with
that so that's working out absolute
salute definitely was playing some pub g
this week wow took it back
yo
it runs so
smooth
so buttery smooth and it's a it's a
different animal right because i play
all these battle royale games i play
fortnite i i play that's like the
original
it it it has a diff it was okay so i got
a chicken dinner right
and it was just me and this one dude and
i threw a grenade i saw him i threw a
grenade and just to flush him out to
make him run this way he didn't he ran
towards the grenade and just started
shooting at me so i went behind the rock
and then that's when my fortnight life
kicked in
i switched to the other weapon and i
slid out i was like i had
let's just go for it yeah and i got the
chicken dinner but it's a whole
different feel like these
every game has its own lane and i can
see why people are still playing pub g
to this day i just gotta you know every
once in a while kick it back up and
that's that's the og originators you
know what i'm saying what's up it's you
could you can definitely make a strong
argument saying that if it wasn't for
that game fortnite never would have came
up
that story is a wild story right yeah i
remember when we were covering that like
that that was a funny thing
oh cd how would you
okay then they gave transformation but
because fortnite was different right
wasn't it like this cooperative
oh we got a battle royale too it was it
was a cooperative like the uh uh defense
game yes yes yeah i remember the
original trailer for fortnite had
nothing to do with nothing
and i remember not being interested and
pub g was all the rage remember yeah it
did it was like kill your game what
killed them is first off
pubg had the building that blew up where
you build
and pubg ran at 60 frames and it was
like
it it like people like to think like
pubg is a casual game it's not but like
the ground floor pub g's are casual yeah
but like competitively pub g's one of
the most competitive
royals out there oh for sure for sure
it's absolutely ridiculous and it's
still ridiculous to this day like but
and they gave so many different quality
of life things that you wished was there
earlier on i know like
that's there now
night and day i'm just surprised there's
not a part two to just go with it with
the glasses still rocking they need to
step down
yo you know the graphics is exactly what
they want yeah
yo it's it's you know what it reminds me
of remember when he's playing so-called
yes
okay so socom graphics wasn't all that
but it had a charm to it
yeah don't don't get me wrong you
correct yeah both of you are correct
with the feel and the tension and the it
just feels good like i can't front it's
just like i look at warzone i'm like
that's what she was supposed to be but
you know is it sacrifice though yeah
absolutely because warzone definitely
don't have that same feel like
it feels finely tuned like
it feels like a war simulator like
you're in a in an army simulator type of
army simulated type i don't even know
with action i don't even think that's
like graphics that's just art style
approach like they chose a different art
style
than other games
what's funny is like that that's all
funny and that's that's cute but who
wouldn't the battle royale games it's
fortnite with their black ass ground
yeah but that war zone that war zone is
right in the mix i'm just saying yeah
i thought it was going to take over yeah
it was hot like a good two bucks
thinking it was over
yo that's what it was remember when it
happened they're just doing guys they're
doing a star wars thing right now yeah
right now i'm fighting darth vader oh
are you all sorry real quick get my all
right so i'm playing fortnite two times
right i come down to my ship and then um
you know how you you launch in the in
the in the travel bus right the boogie
bus yeah and
i saw a ship just fly out i was like
what's that and i thought it was
somebody using a glider right
god came back and then i saw it again
so this time i followed the ship i
looked at it and i and then was like it
was time for us to jump out i jumped out
the boogie bus jumped out the boogie
boats i found i followed it all the way
down
well so
uh it's a [ __ ] with darth vader in it
and he has storm troopers what so they
get out yeah they get out they doing
whatever they doing over there so um i
landed and i grabbed the shotgun
wrong move obi-wan
i
hopped out
i i said let me see how much energy he
got
i shot him
yo he had a red uh exclamation point
over his head oh like don't don't do it
he looked at me you know the rest of the
team had the question once they started
coming up oh they had that better gift
[Applause]
they killed me so bad
darth vader talking mess with me killing
you dog dog yeah i'm like what the hell
is it so he like an event boss or
something yes they have those this is is
those licensees that they have
that make them second to none yeah
that's too much how would you i remember
the fat house glove remember like when i
was hot when they dropped that you get
bad noses gloves are you turning the fan
off yeah they literally got all this i
got a lot of stuff
you can't you came just to play the
surfer yeah
what's funny is we always talk about
like microsoft needs to look try a
little bit more to be more mainstream
and like they're the the kings at that
time
anything
yeah anything remotely popping they're
like yo get to get the people on the
phone
yeah shout out to fortnight man they've
been doing it and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi lord
cognito spreading that willis in the
roman iop not telling you what you want
to hear but what you need to hear shout
out to my man mr maddie please the
defining duke up on last damn media
youtube right now had a good one man
just talking about what's going on with
2022 for the rest of lineup what we
should be excited about giving forza
motorsport it's flowers i know i've been
slaying the wrist but i had to give
credit where credit is due mr slander
as far as graphical fidelity what they
do and it looks fantastic and then we
had this little debate again about
bathroom habits come check that out it's
absolutely hilarious then we had an
ultimate that is only your lifestyle
media patreon we'll talk about the
commitment to jrpgs japanese games by
xbox how we think there could be some
some good ramifications after the
showcase and then uh last word you
already know about bros ibantis ty got
travis just got to talk about what's
going on in the latest story destiny
content vote all that good stuff as far
as games shout out to four guys man i
was playing four guys you know shout out
to dj oral shout out to mange you know
what i'm saying he's getting a little of
joining shout out to bill stillwell epic
games in the building with the epic
games integration has some good four
guys action over there on xbox is real
fun my first time played it i knew it
was coming so it's my first time playing
it just you know it's it's just savagery
it's just knocking people off the map
it's doing all type of stuff to harass
people you know what i'm saying
something doing that and then i got a
shout out to the team shout out to sin
shout out to um follow khan shout out to
kai botsu he's doing that vr that demio
curse of the serpent lord i did our
attic i did pc for the first time i did
the pc edition
had the smooth train the only way to
play that game
so i did the transition where like i
said it had all my progression all that
stuff and i have to admit the ease of
use is really cool i will say of course
the vr experience is way more immersive
and you know what i don't like though
about the pc edition i got to talk to
the devs or something you know how you
look at the character
like usually when they'd be like yo you
stunned it'll tell you what stun does in
detail i've been i've been i've been
saying that like every time yeah i see
what you was talking about because it
doesn't tell you what the statuses are
in in detail so i think there's like an
omission and i definitely want to hit
the devs up and tell they got to have
that position because pc guys are not
going to know what some of these powers
do but um yeah that we had was rocking
that we did want to beat one of the
dungeons and we had we look we had to do
the uh curse of serpent lord over
because i didn't know if you lose on the
boss level you know your save gets wiped
i didn't do that you lose on any level
you're safe before you do not know this
but you you have to leave the
the game
the host has to leave before
the game
like concludes if you want to keep it
safe i didn't realize that because we
got i guess we must have got you know
lost that last time and we was like yo
we don't nobody got the same so anyway
shout out to them it was good shout out
to citizens in the chat i see what's
going on shout out too quickly um aunt
king okay there but aunt the ruler my
cali homie he's up in ny where he was
with black magic they was talking they
hit me up
they hit me up um
and but i was with my son when he was
watching the movie buzzing like yeah
shout out to brothers
uh sinister we have to finish this
destiny stuff uh okay so you're in the
me in the chat i said it to like the pc
edition and we got two legends to iop
family done pulled up in the realm to
hold us down first let's talk to my bro
lord bod's game i feel like i'm gonna
talk to you in a minute miles how are
you doing bro
yeah i'm all good thank you thank you
you're doing great
it's just a little bit hot here in
poland oh just a little bit
wetting and that stuff yeah thanks a lot
for the invite looking forward to all
the interesting topics and stuff and uh
yeah like uh nice to be
be here back again so yeah
come on man it's your home man we
haven't had you in a minute and
of course this is his home
[Laughter]
everything bro as soon as you start
putting all crocs this is what happened
no no i'll be yelling out with four
crocs stop playing with me look man
you're a different type of dude that's
right different type of keep this oh no
oh you got your kids officially tissue
with that i don't know
king gonna
they said your door's open when you
sleep i don't know oh damn boys anyway
see
my door might be wide open right now but
there are no boots in here
whoa
don't addict don't do that
[Laughter]
and return it
the homie rdx podcast the legend himself
and we miss his podcast too i love that
guy shout out to my boy jay fosurelli
man what's going on bro thank you
brother uh yeah you can hear me right
yeah yes sir
good good that radio voice we love uh
yeah it's great to be back in the
community casting again my show will be
back next week by the way and i will
none other than the ash and lucas
starting off season two oh you got the
debut yeah yeah yeah i know that game
gotta come on let's go i i've been
waiting for uh luca for some time she
said you know what wait till i get my
cam and i will be on your show
by the way by the way luca tells me
fonz don't give me no questions like you
do other people
you're gonna get the five questions work
and you're gonna like it okay
but no i i i love luca yeah
she's great she's been a she's been a
good friend for so many years and i
cannot wait to have that one-on-one with
her yes uh you'll definitely get to know
her a bit better if you don't already
know her
um yeah come check out the show next
week it'll be fun your show is fire love
the questions you know how i feel about
that 80s retro feel
it's like a game show oh that's what i'm
talking about what i like is you do it
yeah he does what no one else is doing
you have your own lane brother really
cool to see
and uh i think we could put the shrimps
in the chat y'all
i think we could put the shrimps in the
chat lord jasmine is that jess my check
i i ain't gonna lie jess we we had
twitter come after you yeah we
definitely bullied you into finding our
way out
yeah we put a hit out well i put the
head out that's
you already know he said scripts put the
scripts in the chat yo y'all
so we're waiting for jess to get his
bike together so i will do the poll last
week's sports results in the people have
spoken with the final fantasy 7 25th
anniversary event showcasing the remake
part 2 as ps5 exclusive do you think
it's fair that xbox is missing out on
this title the winner of the iop post
like 60
of the vote was i don't care y'all
better keep that same energy when it's a
game y'all don't care about group
okay the people have said what they had
to say there then actually coming in
second place is actually a tie it's
really a dead heat with um 20
of the votes saying no exclusives bring
identity to each platform if you truly
care about the game buy the game or the
platform exists and also tied was yes
secretly extending exclusivity deals
just to get keep the game off xbox is
unfair to xbox fans and the overall
success of the game lord addict this is
a contentious one where you act with
your final fantasy man
all right so can you repeat that sorry
so pretty much people said people said
no you could do it people said that
people
need to care i don't care people one
because they say y'all better keep the
same energy when it's a game you care
about what you don't care about so and
then the other thing is
a dead heat some people like yo they got
the right exclusives or exclusives buy
the game where the platform's at and
other people like nah they they you know
doing xbox 30 so to speak so well yeah
no i i think both could be right it's
like look like you know that's what
timed exclusives are for uh to give
value to a platform but don't think i
ain't gonna hold my platform responsible
for not getting that game like
regardless if they didn't get that game
and there wasn't probably a lot
microsoft can do to get that game right
i'm still gonna make my voice heard i
would have preferred you guys to get
that game because that way when that
final fantasy nine remake comes out
they're like yo attic won't shut up if
we have another
if we lose another one
never gonna like let us look that down
oh i see him i see him i mean
i'm glad to see you glad you could make
it and i don't even have a good excuse
and completely lost track of time i was
like right i'll have my dinner
i'll have my dinner at four so i can get
ready for the show i had my dinner and i
was playing out worlds like okay i got
about 45 minutes
and i just completely lost track of time
i'm so sorry all right what's the
profession you only get off the hook
what dlc was you doing or when you do a
base game
oh i was doing um the what's it called
perils of gorgon oh god okay
said that he was having dinner at four
because you know this is a five-hour
podcast you're gonna be having a second
dinner after this
but you have to be reasonable for us
we don't
when he leaves the podcast he got to
leak something like that
so jazz bet what's going on what you've
been playing man
oh man i've just been uh
it's been a busy couple of weeks because
of the whole e3 stuff and um
i don't know why i got i got an itch to
play the other world for some reason i
think it was the star field trailer yeah
yeah i was like you know i wanna i'll
get into some star field light while i
wait yeah you know and uh so i've been
playing that a bit um
you didn't feel like playing
i've been playing some diablo too oh wow
because
mortal turned out to be a
[ __ ] show
so i was like and i was like i still
want to play diablo so i'll i'll go back
to the classics
i've just been playing random stuff you
know trying to get into the backlog a
bit yeah get that back take care that's
what's up
i never played there at worlds dlc so
yeah i highly recommend murder at
eurodollars even though gorgart is good
funny story good funny choice at the end
you had to do yeah murder or eridanos to
me is god tier that's that's them at
their best it's just
it's just wild it's wacky but i don't
want to spoil it but i'm glad i'm glad
you're hitting that up that's what's up
man no doubt glad you could make it also
mods real quick man i've got to ask you
what have you been playing sir
well uh lately i've been playing fallout
76 because um you know after that uh
star field reveal
uh i got that fallout vibe actually you
know it's actually funny because a lot
of people before the
starter field uh trailer gameplay
trailer
uh although people said uh we were
saying that oh it's going to be
basically just um
skyrim in space right but you know after
after the gameplay trailer um i'm like
yeah it's i've go i'm getting like
really that the um
fallout vibes right so i just like i
never played fallout 76 so let me give
it a try and look glass and so far so
good i must say so
yeah and over and over than that like
you know a little bit of forza a little
bit of uh you know uh ninja turtles and
that kind of stuff so yeah a little bit
of everything really so i'm actually
i'm actually getting ready to play uh
like you know the half-life games
because there's there's steam sales
going on right now and i pretty much
bought them all right now so
it will take me a while but yeah it's uh
you know love these games so yeah so
that's that's what i've been playing
here no doubt shout out to mother no
five step the way i should ask him what
he's been playing but hopefully he comes
back he's taking care of business but uh
we gotta get into the show man we got
some topics we just went to grab some
lunch with the guests of life
yeah yeah he went to go get last night
he was hungry he's worried about jeff
anyway so we're gonna get into it y'all
so look um king i'm gonna set you off
because this is your new topic your top
is a kind of split we'll do the first
one will be this and then we'll do the
last one which is kind of your original
problem this kind of came across our
line so you know we figured we'd bring
it to the king's attention so yeah shout
out to you know xbox series x and s out
selling ps5 in japan and it said as
sony's hybrid by supply issues twice as
many xbox consoles than ps5 was sold to
japan last week so shout out to famitsu
looks like the xbox series console
family sold 6 695 units during that
period of june 13th through the 19th
which eclipsed ps5 3000 sales um i'll
talk about the breakdowns individually
when we talk but um then again this is
that's the second time because again the
first time was may
9th through the 15th and that's when it
initially happened when we originally
did the topic yeah that's when we had uh
jeff grebber on yeah
[Music]
a little bit too harsh well we got to
give kegan's flowers like we were on
them like i'm not uh
but to say i was clowning him by saying
i needed to see more weeks is a little
how many weeks more do you need to see i
know i literally just told you i'm going
to give you your flowers
i was given
a crazy king japanese little man
hey
king are you saying are you saying that
you bought all these x books did you
have something from japan did you buy
all these kids quiet as scared
you are you something to do with the
supply issues quiet
i'm gonna connect with japan
the new marketing team
in japan is me
yes yes
how are you
i told you
i told you hey dudes this is this is why
i tell you guys
live it up
live it up feel it feel a moment grab it
seize the moment
all right cuz little man this is the
whole reason why
see i couldn't do this with a
playstation 5. but the one with the disc
without the disc you ain't doing no
one-hand display you're not doing this
you're not doing this so when when
the asian market said
this can fit in my house this business
one-handed old man is really small
really cool you know it's crazy king
yeah little man is selling without no
games in 2022. tell them
is is that not scary because when the
games do come mm-hmm
how is it possible why would someone
want something that don't happen
regarding twitter according to twitter
it's it's not even that if you look
gamepad look like
xbox series x only like was hundred or
two hundred less than the series s yeah
so that's like it's it's crazy the
breakdown is interesting because that's
i guess that's the part that's about
i'll give it give it back to king but um
yeah the part that surprised me was
literally the breakdown because
obviously you know we're gonna mention
we're not going to not mention supply
constraints but they did say that
individually the s sold 3 423 units but
what surprised me was the ax sold 3 000
almost just as much 372. and the reason
why i guess i'm surprised that i i'll
open it up back to king's just that i
was at the impression because the s was
the smaller sleek
console that the x really wouldn't have
any traction so to kill what do you
think is going on with that well they
said nobody wanted it
they said see you can't force somebody
to purchase something they don't want i
don't care if it's available or not
right uh the playstation 5 how come is
these supply constraints with people i
think everybody in this room has a
playstation 5.
right everybody here has a playstation
5. yes
i do feel like look they are hard to get
but at this point
can you let me finish my statement you
could but that's a lot easier
i i said they they are hard to get but
if you
you if you were trying you would have
one by now it's just people people they
they do the bare minimum and say i can't
get one
true it's true i don't i don't believe
about are you talking about xbox or
playstation playstation
if you really want one you can actually
pay for one you know go to stockx
y'all gonna sit here i'm not gonna allow
these dudes to run around with their the
supply constraints king because you know
if it was there are supplies
look like there's nothing no we can't
actually get it no man
it's who fault is that i don't care
let me just say this much because i'll
say this
i know some die hard xbox dude they got
a playstation through stockx yep
okay because they they just wanted one
okay can someone explain to me about
stock access pockets is a supply store
that can actually get you everything
that you're looking for right now for
market price i just i just wait for
them to show up on best buy like sooner
or later they do show up at best buy and
they make you go to the stores so like
it's a lot i've got three xbox series
x's and two ps5 because of a best buy
so i mean i mean
here in here in poland you can actually
get places five well like you cannot
really get you cannot like walk into the
store and get one but online no problem
the only thing is that you it always
comes with something extra like
oh like a bundle
yeah i can't walk into any store around
here and get a series
okay okay
it's just a bunch of lies of
fabrications right so to to distract
from exactly what's really happening
told you dudes y'all can be happy and
live in a moment oh it's selling it's
actually doing something it has actually
some type of traction remember the the
last generation was a hiccup right it
was it was we was rolling everything was
rolling fine next the xbox the first
xbox then the 360 everything was rolling
fine then the dude messed up and you
know we had just restart the whole thing
this is the start of a different
generation fonz brought up something
that was very very key
if there's no games because there's
really no really heavy hitting games
next gen or the current gen games now
will be starting to come next year and
when that ball starts to roll they're
doing all of this off of the strength of
rebranding the company as far as
consumer friendly giving game pass game
pass giving you options when you're
going to buy
it's changing how people see it
and i said it was an awakening in japan
when people got up and brought six
thousand i'm like what happened that day
and you know y'all was clowning me that
was like ah nothing happened that day it
just sold and it ain't gonna sell next
week well it's so the week after the
week after the weekend
and it's continued to do so it's too
it's too it feels it's too late and i'm
just saying
doing what they're not supposed to do
and be honest
i'm pretty surprised that the way it's
sold right i really am yeah i'm going to
get jess's thoughts on it just in
general you know with the with this you
know obviously the news came out and it
sold again you know are you are you on
the side of is it strictly the supply
constraint issue or do you think to
king's point it could be a sign of
something greater where where do you
stand on this chest
i think well the fact that they're
selling through all their stock is
you know a good thing it'd be it would
be it'd be a travesty if we had like
they had had like a few thousand units
on shore store shelves and they
weren't selling out given the supply
constraints so you know i think like i
think supply constraints is a
real thing you know you kind of you
reduce the the visibility of your
product you reduce the the potentiality
for
uh that's not a word do you reduce the
potential
[Laughter]
so you reduce the potential for impulse
purchases like when you're walking into
a store you want to buy some
landscape products for example
and um
and uh and then you see a playstation 5
there you're like oh yeah i'll just get
a playstation okay maybe no no maybe not
a lot of people impulse purchase of
playstation 5. but that the product
visibility is reduced when there's no
stock on storage series s is an impulse
buyer i'll say that yeah
that's exactly it though series s
definitely is an impulse buy and there
are games like fortnite and halo
infinite and forza and you know four
guys and sort of these trending kind of
games which
just look and perform better on the
series s like if you've got a
playstation 4 for example if you've got
a playstation 4 or a nintendo switch
even and you want to play if you've got
if you're in if you're a nintendo switch
user and you want to play a game that's
higher than 15 frames per second the the
oh
javi's consoled by if you're budgeting
already this is serious right
you know it's like man i'm trying to
play fortnite on this on this you know
paperweight thing
and it's like well i could play on
something something that's a bit faster
you know
both both in terms of ssd and frame rate
and all the rest of it so
and then you factor in xbox game pass as
well and it's like you were saying
earlier like they're doing all this
without the heavy hitting exclusives
right yeah it's all being driven by
games like fortnite and it's being
driven by you know
the value of game pass and the impulse
purchase and it looks great and it's
tidy it's great for you know younger
siblings it's a great
great gift to get a younger sibling or a
younger child or something it's just
it's so it's the right product for the
right time yeah you know just could be
that in five yeah it could be that in
five years maybe
maybe it stops being the right product
and it starts the sales start slowing
down by which time they'll have a series
x probably in higher supply maybe they
can drop us a
price cart permanent price card on the
series x or whatever but i remember when
they announced the series s there was a
lot of people like oh two console
launched that makes no sense it's a
terrible idea but it's like nah phone
manufacturers have been doing this for
for decades you know they launch your
phone they launch your phone for the
lower end i want your phone for a
higher end and i have a million phones
in between and you know even just the
the mere suggestion of having two skus
yeah blew some people's minds yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] imagine box of
no you're absolutely right they said the
consumer is going to be confused the
point was confusion it is not going to
work remember that that was the argument
get it out i'm sorry ridiculous imagine
how crazy it would be if there was only
a windows 11 and like an android note
like you know what i'm saying like like
you know it would be the gauss you'd
probably be the base model like just a
windows
not a windows uh just a a note
or a galaxy probably a galaxy
and just an ipo a and an iphone that's
all like there's no
there's no nothing else there's no like
five skus of each phone you walk in
imagine how how little like the the
actual cell phone productions would have
to be it's literally just like just one
table in the middle of the place on one
side it has an iphone and the other side
of it has a galaxy no it's a good point
because at the end you know what yeah
the whole confusion uh the
them talking about how it's confusing
for some people like
if
your background
like little timmy's grandma goes into
the store and she doesn't you know know
the difference between the x and the s
and that's fine but all the little timmy
has to do is get the black one mom
you know
are you implying that the confusion
narrative was overblown for a little bit
oh you were perfect sure i knew that
from the beginning i mean i've always
hated that oh the more skews you know
than just one is just total confusion
yeah no to be honest
who's really going to be looking
to be honest with you the only people
that's going to be looking for like the
heart for like that the x is the
hardcore the the casual most likely is
going to go in there for the cheapest
product anyway so like you can't get
three to 500 just like confused like no
no we got kiss move the best buy in the
building what's going on he definitely
wanted it on this topic this is his
family
you guys had a full house and i had the
family's gone my house is silent i'm
watching the podcast they're like oh
there's a little light on ilp today i
was like i wonder if i'll get that
invitation
pop up i was like oh jazz mads oh come
on let me in here
wait wait wait wait wait a minute wait a
minute i i can hear smoove and there's
no kids in the background i know that's
the first hit
that's amazing you put on his party time
shirt
you're about to have a party in the crib
i feel like house party three and he
threw on his crocs he outside
don't you do it
[Laughter]
it's like the rebel and i'm coming out
the moment she leaves i mean i'm putting
on this shirt on that shirt that she
don't like she locked the door he put
the shirt off
he gonna have the door locked and she's
knocking on the door jerry like jeffrey
why you ain't opening the door he's like
trying to switch the shirt real quick
yeah yo when she left i had a lakers
jersey on it
pulled the green screen up anyway okay
let's get back on man so so what do you
think man you know obviously this is the
second time this has happened you know
we you know the talk is clearly that
they still could uh supply constraint
interest for playstation but you know
how are you taking this news of of uh
xbox series s and x success in japan
it's uh it's the change that nobody
wanted to see um
and it's i know every article is crazy
that every article has to pre-face every
time they announce that the xbox is out
selling the playstation 5 in japan they
have to say supply constraints yeah
right it's like they don't every time
this crazy thing is when playstation is
winning in japan right when they sell
out normally outside xbox japan no word
of it when it does it in the uk no word
of it right no despite
shortages playstation manages to outsell
this
only when the xbox is doing it and it's
crazy and people are like this is going
to go back to the right i keep that
comment it's going to go back to normal
bg
you got to catch a bullet i'm like
so
i'm like okay so this is the only time
this is going to occur
and the thing is it's not like it's now
think about it xbox on average yes
historically sells about 900 units
that's true no that's a good point it's
been selling literally
half a dozen to a dozen which is kind of
not normal for xbox and the thing is if
you're out selling playstation that
means playstation has to be selling less
than that
so
it uh this week the last time it outsold
playstation it was in the six seven
thousands right yeah and a week prior to
that when it didn't outsell places it
sold more right it sold six thousand
eleven
yeah
i'm with you
and then the week uh the week prior to
that it was like around seven thousand
but please show maybe around like nine
or eleven right
and then this time around how much did
they sell was like 12
12 k yeah right now yeah total total
looks like yeah i don't hype with all
the sales and everything but i will say
that you know it was shocking to me
um i guess not really shocking because
in the end it really is the most
brilliant move that microsoft could have
done bringing out this console at this
price point at what it can do as well
um you know it's it's amazing like my
son has one i you know he's had one for
months now and he loves it
radio not the radio [ __ ]
that's what's so dope about it he's
switching up his backgrounds and he's
giving you that feel i love the fact
that he got the old school bull box oh i
got to put it on fire
old school because he do look like an
old school boy shout out to little man
looking like an old school full box
boom box it plays video games
salute no actually correction um kid it
was on my i got it wrong it said the
xbox series family of course so both of
them like i said 6 000 units total with
a 3 000 kind of unit split per yeah the
kind of thing but yeah i mean it's very
interesting i'll let you go then i'll
jump in aftercare i'm sorry
um
oh jessica at least
at least it's get everybody's getting
what they want you know because they
shouldn't be counting it together they
should split them up
now they split
[Laughter]
is i was looking both consoles outsold
the playstation 5. like both of them did
so
there was they were separately huh yeah
that's both separately outsoldered
you know it's funny like
when the switch was out when the switch
had supply restraints and it was outside
the playstation there was no oh with
resp supply restraints you know
it does seem like it's a little bit
one-sided but you know at the end of the
day it is japan and uh you know they
they're doing a lot better uh i like
that because it hopefully
more of these japanese developers will
take it more seriously when they're
talking about branding
king said you got double teamed and
lumped up twice for real so now i'm
gonna take on your big homie oh oh oh
but you know what what's interesting
about about japan is that um like and
not many people actually talk about it
because like many people like focuses on
like xbox versus playstation and and
let's bring a little bit of like uh you
know uh reality
yeah what are we gonna talk about
like like the xbox one twice
or uh and each time it was because of
the fact that playstation 5 so as sales
so it dropped from from like 15 000 to
2000 right
so yes it's uh obviously the
shortages and that kind of stuff but
if you look at the number numbers like
ever since they launched in japan right
and compared to
uh how many consoles they were selling
last generation yes we're talking
we're talking about like huge boost in
sales yes like last generation they they
would sell 200 300 500 consoles a week
that xbox one error was brutal now
2 000 3000 is minimum yes so we're
talking about at least 10 15 times uh
boost in sales in japan
with no games right so that's that's
history that's the impression
yeah so yes playstation 3
but they are doing very well in japan
good job
you have to remember as well a lot of
the a lot of the silicon they're getting
for
the consoles is going straight into x
cloud yes so a lot of the like a lot of
the
the chips they're manufacturing which
are series x chips
they're not putting them into consoles
they're sticking them straight in the
server
yeah and sending that to japan
so like it's kind of like you know how
how many how many de facto player xbox
gamers are there in japan because of
xcloud which has started hitting
capacity recently
like sometimes during peak hours they'll
say you are now into you are now in a
queue to play xcloud so it's like people
are using it you know yeah so um there's
that's that aspect of it as well no
absolutely that's a fantastic straining
their own supply yeah they're literally
cut into their own supply because of
yeah the azure server blades that we
know they went from wouldn't that make
uh supply constraints on the xbox high
i'm just i'm just saying i mean if we're
losing using that logic right if you're
taking half of your product and you're
putting your product someplace else and
you're not distributing it into the
consumers and you're just selling
exactly half
so they beating your behind with one
hand tied behind their back this is kind
of crazy here we go you're out here with
all your supplies your supplies ain't
going down
no but you didn't say it but i did
here we go
your whole supply is going to the
consumers everything you got and get go
to consumers microsoft's sold so nice
with it they say yo split it up
take one yo throw that over there put
that to the cloud and what we're going
to these we sell these to the people
selling them yeah with one hand tied
behind our back so what happens when all
the cloud service is good
oh that is on it's on okay i see what we
do the games yeah all the games come out
y'all in trouble right now see y'all
should've never gave me that ammo see i
love you you know it's a simple fact
that just just broke it down for you and
told you
when i could just giving it to the cloud
y'all gonna get this work
can i can just see right now phil
spencer's sitting his little ife tower
and the moment the moment those cloud
servers are built then he just gets that
call and he's like i'm initiate order
eighteen eighties are we doing that
that's what we're doing now
here
yeah
quick question to jess because like you
know when you listen to king it's you
know you you feel like oh they are
putting like millions of districts into
their server right
but that's probably not the case right
so like i know that you keep your you
know close to the ground uh on these
things so
what kind of numbers we potentially we
can be talking about like hundreds of
thousands of these chips or like tens of
thousands of because let's just say like
i know really yeah but there's no it's
not like
it's not millions but yeah you have to
assume like
you can kind of extrapolate some
ballpark estimates based on the fact
that you know
um
it needs xbox game pass right and it's
25 as far as we know there's 25 million
xbox game past subscribers now
they haven't officially released the
breakdown of what's getting past
ultimate subscribers and what's not
but like you know just assume that like
10 of those a game pass
cloud actively gain past cloud users
game pass cloud
active users you got it and then you
need you need a few million servers
probably you know and
they're sort of like they're not even
really advertising it either that's a
good point because they know that if
they start advertising it they're going
to hit capacity issues and like if
they're in these they're only putting
yeah it's officially it's still in
better which basically
i think the the reason they call it is
because it's like a slow rollout you
know they don't want to start
advertising it and to turn uh turn the
gas on because
they'll they'll blow up their servers
right
and um that's why like they're rolling
it out to a subset of samsung tvs this
year rather than all tvs you know tell
them um
part of it yeah part of it is that the
samsung tvs have some encoding tech in
them but imagine if they just went and
slapped the browser version of xcloud on
every tv isn't it and then
damn then then you know you're gonna hit
server issues but don't tell them um
there's no way to know there's no way i
don't know so could be could be hundreds
of thousands but they did say one thing
they did say was
over the next 12 months they're going to
add 125
additional server capacity to xcloud
so they're they're more than doubling
the amount of silicon going to growing
xcloud which could be consoles going to
japan or going to store shelves right
at it got his hand over there
it's just one thing soon as addict
finished it's just one thing that i want
to say because
jess brought up a great point i i do
appreciate you educating me jess
um
because
they're doing this without even
advertising oh my god
oh my god
it's so impressive
with word of mouth oh my god
[Laughter]
are you implying that what's the
floodgates here in the
servers and once you see what jess did
tell you is once they say go jazz and
then he actually able to promote
i'm clipping that oh my god
this is crazy
they're doing it with one hand tied
behind their back without broadcasting
they doing it
in trouble now this is the best i i've
waited for this position i waited eight
long years struggling i'm not even gonna
front you guys think it's a joke you're
like oh king you be fanboy in this
console stuff hell yes i do
so so when dude's like nah man i'm
partially on this side i don't care
where yet but what i'm saying you know
what's that you're a kid i think that's
clear the facts right yes the fact is
they're not sending all of their ammo in
one spot
and they're selling out selling other
dudes with one hand tied behind his back
for two weeks he's not telling nobody
about it
so they're keeping it to themselves
while working them and when they start
telling and they got both hands out it's
going to be a slaughter i don't care
what y'all got coming
i just want to say like
when do you think sony is able to
consistently meet this supply demand
like when do you think they would be
able to solve the fight's over
the king
that was not the case
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was his answer that was easy
let me give it to you and adding you
said your point because i always told
you like what do you think they could be
able to resolve it because clearly that
that like to kid smooth's point when we
do see the articles it is usually the
asterisk or the caveat you know because
of p playstation 5 constraint issues you
know supply issues stuff like that but
what do you think they could able
because this is this is a long time like
basically what i'm getting at is
when
besides when do we think it'd be over
like because at some point playstation
has to address this issue right what do
you think they get that solvent then we
could have like a this another
assessment of it
i mean we're what
almost two years into the into this
generation
i i kind of like i'm not going to go
with king 100
but maybe by the time they get the grasp
on this this situation it might be too
late because it's just like look
they've said multiple times in the past
the beginning of the generation is the
most vital now i'm not saying that
microsoft's just gonna start out selling
sony like three to four to one or two to
three to one even but what i am saying
is this is the kind of thing that
microsoft needed coming off the last
generation yeah to make the numbers more
even right uh because it doesn't matter
if sony doesn't be able to uh you know
meet the man it's like when we had david
jaffe on here he said
sony had the same opportunities they
could have dropped the bag too but they
chose not to that's one so making sure
yeah
okay
look microsoft's always had that money
but sony could have easily have you know
done different things they didn't
anticipate how long this would last it
seems it's just like
no one can deny it they're doing better
in japan if they're doing better in
areas where they were getting absolutely
demolished last generation not a little
bit a lot yeah yeah i can't imagine what
they're doing everywhere else like we're
seeing 10
increase in in a country that first off
probably a lot of the the products
aren't welcome in general
uh second off you know if you guys ever
seen like the little sections that's at
their stores it's small xbox is small in
those sections but they're still
outselling
local hardware
and that that speaks volume itself look
it's like i said
you know they they're doing better when
it brings to you know the personas
uh to get past like
that that demographic sees that they say
oh i can get this and get every yakuza
game
uh you know for the most part every
y'all cause a game and they know for a
fact like i said
it doesn't matter where you live in the
world value is still value
when you can walk in and leave with i
don't know what you know uh currency
exchange it is over there but uh you
could walk in and leave with uh with a
series s and not to mention x is still
selling really good oh that's the
surprise you can leave with a series s
with a month of game pass
that screams volume that screams value
and they they clearly see that what are
you doing i think it's true
i want to back you up on that a bit when
you're talking about when you walk into
a retail store and you see like the
playstation section is always a lot
bigger
and that has a lot to do with even
perception you know
and i think a lot of people well
retailers in the past they allocate uh
for the stock they they think okay
playstation sells more we need to have
more stock for playstation items right
well if this continues and this becomes
you know more of a trend going forward
you're going to see that section get
bigger and bigger for xbox as well so
yeah it's just
good
then when you see more of a demand over
there then you you'll start to see
these companies they're like look you
there's been multiple interviews and i'm
pretty sure jess can contest to this
where
phil's been over there talking to
developers and they say yo we can't
really take your product serious because
we don't see your product in our store
but now they're seeing more people with
it and you know it's one thing to
develop on a game
and not release that game on a platform
because your friends don't have it your
your family doesn't have it no one you
know has an xbox but the more you start
to like level that out i'm not saying
it's selling crazy amounts but it's
selling okay over there considering it's
it's a country that's kind of one away
from console gaming in general like we
could act like the playstation sells
like millions over there they don't what
switches down you know they so they so
good over there but
that is a very mobile state and i think
people are picking up the series s and
the x because they have x cloud because
they want more access to the games that
they get with that service and they're
going to use the console to get it who
did that for you
yes you know let me give a balls over
could this you guys build good points i
mean at the other day it's like it is
impressive to me it is impressive i know
people will use a caveat of supply
issues and i'm not going to say that
they're not for sony you know but at
some point you know we have to give
credit to one company having the
foresight to plan especially in a region
that historically they didn't do well in
right so this is important and to me
it's like what king and jesus is saying
it's like
at the end of the day in france you said
as well when you walk in as retail you
know the the perception is you go in
there to get what you want right if what
you want is not there you know yes will
there be some times when someone says
okay you know maybe i'll get this other
thing but generally you'll wait until
what you want is resupplied so to me
there is a demand for something
especially on the twitter you know
there's no reason to have an xbox right
so not to interrupt you yes please so
you're saying that the consumer is going
inside the store and they have this
large playstation section and he says
excuse me can i have a
and he lockheart he says well uh we have
the new playstation 5 over he says sorry
sir can i have a lockhart they're not
using the code
but it has the premium service uh you
know no i like game pass and a lockhart
please
clear how big your section is pause i'm
going home what what a little man
it's a testament a little bit yes it's a
testament to how big your section is
it's a testament to one the shout out to
the you know the the team obviously
jason ryan and his team from uh from a
hardware from an architectural
standpoint it's a well-designed console
we cannot dismiss that second we cannot
dismiss the value right so clearly you
know again people have to understand
twitter is is that's just an echo
chamber that does not represent real
life you know so at the end of the day
it does not so at the end of the day
so when people go in like i said they're
seeing value they're seeing something
they wanted regardless even if you know
because supply constraints by
playstation does get rectified and
playstation sells more whatever
it is impressive based on what they did
last generation but let's be honest was
paltry you know it was something that
that wasn't really even taken serious
and i think combined with that combined
with the the commitment to japanese
games obviously we know about the kojima
thing we know about what they're doing
saying we're not doing with the atlas it
we're starting to see again it almost
feels like that 360 where there's a
presence they may never win the region
but to have a presence in an area where
historically it's been bad wait king we
doing that i think they're gonna win
that oh god here we go okay here we go
the nintendo switch is the market
leadership we're acting like the
nintendo switch that is existing first
of all we're not talking about that
though oh we don't talking about that
today
we're gonna keep it a buck we're not
talking about that weird thing that
sells the weird thing oh it's a weird
it's a concept
that's the sister ain't got no games oh
still selling that's a real sister with
no games
shout out to
them doing whatever who cares nobody
cares
you can't say nobody cares about this
i don't care
you know what i wish we could have that
we can have the video of that dude on
espn says no one cares yeah yeah let me
let me let me live with this world kicks
again but but no no no because i'm you
know what they're gonna start saying
oh you know when the playstation starts
selling all the because the supply
constraints was up now you see what
happened no
no see and i want y'all i want y'all to
temper your expectations
you want to play
for the expectations what i'm gonna do
to them what they what microsoft what
they wanted microsoft to do
temple your expectations the thing is
okay in the next 12 months what's going
to happen is
soon in the near future
microsoft won't need to send anything to
the cloud server
it did it's all and that's when the
fight and the weapons is going to stop
so i'm going to tell you right now under
the score
go get yourself a lockhart
right and then tune in and get yourself
game pass ultimate and just buckle in
eat your popcorn and have a good time
because the slaughter is going to be
fantastic and don't be apologetic guys
with you what is this retribution
with them listen they had caskets i
remember dudes putting me on memes with
caskets with the xbox you don't remember
they had a great time you know planning
our demise oh this generation could go
just like last generation plot twist
it's not
and then doing it they're doing it off
of the words of jess
it's okay thank you
thank you thank you
what what happens when like you know we
talk about people saying oh can you can
you count the style separately can you
cancel separately
what about when they released the xbox
handheld in japan oh exclusively
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
here's the question
native or like a clown like how you had
the kishi version two article like what
what would the speculation incur
oh man speculatively it's a speculative
i don't know
speculatively i imagine it would be a
cloud kind of okay okay okay okay but it
dedicated speculatively okay yeah
speculatively the the keystone
an operating system not necessarily
hardware so necessarily a keystone
operating system that did cloud stuff
that's the kind of thing you put in the
handheld
lights their handhelds right
the xbox series y or something oh c's
x x
no no i was gonna say so you're implying
that the project keystone could lead to
a bigger initiative potentially
speculatively expected we all just
speculated that's what we're doing
it's a reach
would it make sense to even do that if
they can just like put this os on other
existing devices there's so many of them
out there i think i think the reason i
put it on everything oh put it on
everything
i i think the reason is like
sorry guys
i was just gonna say i think the reason
that they would make a like a
personalized handheld device is because
the switch is can seen is like a
personalized handheld device and i feel
like they might want to build something
a little bit more natural to the hand
phone
you got to think right you guys think a
lot a lot of
a lot of the
the encoding for the video stream for
cloud some of that's done natively right
some of that's done on your device like
that's why the pc version of xcloud
tends to have a better image quality
than if you're just running it through a
browser or something else because
they're sort of they're doing some
compute using you
your computer some encoding right so if
you if you're gonna have dedicated
hardware to streaming cloud
theoretically you could get a better
video stream if the device is actually
designed for it natively that is true
that is true and then theoretically
speculative regulatively
that's um something i think i'd like to
say from them you know for markets that
do
think highly of the 15 fps nintendo
switch get a 60fps cloud xbox switch
instead well look you know it's a
perfect there's a perfect transition
into our next topic because um with the
advancement that xbox is making but i
did want to i didn't want to give you
that because a dedicated i'll be honest
like i i think the tech is really great
i use the key sheet one i got to get to
part two shout out to your article but i
have to say like it is really impressive
it's really responsive it's come a long
way
and if you had a dedicated device oh
put it back up on the screen let me let
me see because i need the new version
left flex put it backwards that's good
right there
okay okay there you go mine are flexible
it's the best it's the best x-class
device right like if it feels great like
you can hear the clickiness of it the
trick is looking back feels like if my
if microsoft made one of these it would
be basically like this right it's the
closest
the closest to actually like feeling
like a good device but probably my
galaxy fold doesn't fit in this thing
and that's dude i'm big so you know it's
it's kind of like i still
still want a dedicated hardware for it
right and that's what part of me feels
like they need a dedicated one because
phones are evolving to a point where
you know when the phones start becoming
popular because i've noticed a lot of
people really are gravitating toward
those phones right
it would be nice for them to have just
one thing you can buy that they're
always going to support right and the
thing is it would solve two problems one
because that's because a person like me
i know i like to use my phone and some
people don't want to have their phone
also multitask as this dual device so
you keep the phone separate have the
dedicated thing and then it helps xbox
because let's be honest even though i
want a native handheld device ultimately
that would be another skew that
potentially xbox would have to develop
for right and this eliminates that if
they would have a dedicated advice
screen and it's still a streaming only
kind of device
that would eliminate that they could
still do what they want to do with uh
project
keystone
you know what that means though don't
you you guys know what that means that
they make uh this this handheld version
that accesses streams
and in the cloud means people are going
to be on twitter i want them separated i
don't want this one
three times those numbers to count i
mean look at the end of the day
after the xbox one generation if you
would have told me the last couple years
of the xbox one that the next xbox would
be out selling playstation it's native
country and that it would be outselling
xbox and
key ports of the world at certain months
i just said you crazy like there ain't
no way he was going to do it all natty
and i told you all that was going to
happen and dudes were looking at me and
laughing and i was like king you're out
here you're capping too hard and what
happened all right i'm going to start
putting some respect on my name
can i talk can i talk
okay
we gotta move on i i would i would have
told you look like it's not happening
because if you look at it from the
logistics of what was going on last
generation so being outsold three to one
everywhere in the world
xbox got no business where it is right
now it's the hard work that the team
made the the rebranding that they did
the restructuring of how the the the
xbox images seen in the world that's
what led to this and there's not a lot
of companies that could have done this
turnaround in just one generation some
companies could never do this turn
around no i agree i agree and that's why
i want to give i don't want to get too
crazy with the just the weak i'm looking
at the overall picture that's how i'm
looking at because regardless of what
the overall pictures that they're doing
better in the region yeah this is an
exciting time i want to transition
straight into the next one i had to get
the super chats ready but i want to
transition to the next one and they're
ready okay you're right okay cool cool
so let's go let's go let's get the um so
we got a five dollar strip from
hollywood rules another spicy iop sunday
with
any key talk welcome back king aka uh
killer croc
have a great show gentlemen how the
mpd's looking watch the goal post move
yeah
then we got a five dollar stretch from
hard i find fortnite so yeah i stepped
with your voice you was using it wrong
i know you guys involved that was a ball
i like that
all right so then we got a five dollar
super chat from parkerkill at nine
thousand probably butchered that it's
cool
uh lord addict how about you how about
you try my name again i probably
butchered it my but my apologies
uh where is the mayo guy aka jazz cord
and he must be sleeping so that that was
the right mayo is in the building
from ryan gether
hey king did you get final fantasy 7 on
game pass
no well you couldn't
i got it on my playstations that's
available in all stores right now still
getting out soon okay can i okay can i
finish the super chat
may i finish the super chat yeah you can
get it go for it so um hey king did you
get final fantasy 7 on game pass nah
well team blue got you boo boo keep up
the great work lords also happy to see
fonz making his uh his return you're all
happy to see funny
let me play with your choice oh oh
song's not here
don't tell saul
but jizz is kind of looking cute today
wait you cheating on solve already all
it took was all it took was jess carter
to come in here and can you play with my
joystick already cheating on us all
right
we're going to find out super different
which is augustus the xbox number in
japan is consistent they sell about six
to 10k per week people only pay
attention when they out sell sony
then we got a new member man put put
some uh put some logo uh
chris in the in the chat man tony brown
new member uh welcome to lord broads man
welcome to laurel thank you
put some chests in that crash thing you
know only xbox got this he said he said
nobody's playing with nobody's joystick
let that man live his life only on xbox
that's how he want to do why worry about
what you do you let him do it
let him do what he want what he's doing
you ain't approaching
your business
why are you looking
[Laughter]
worry about your elite controller
there's no fighters
like we got some jazz corn uh
people in here tom henderson body jeff
uh scrub i assume you talk about grub
and jess corden so i don't know i guess
i guess he feels like maybe he predicted
something you guys didn't i don't
no sense but i understand by your name
no don't buy a game but you don't buy
game pass you go buy your game i'm
trying to promote that crap yeah
and don't subscribe to game pass you
couldn't subscribe for two dollars oh my
god jeff grubbs said i wish tom would
body me
chef
what's going on
we got a new member put some uh crest in
the chat man for uh buddha time oh
welcome to the world what's up
building absolutely got to find out
super chat from donataku xbox and
playstation 5 fighting for second place
just so this time
you know what the greatest thing in the
gaming industry was when the switch came
out we stopped hearing about sales yeah
your sales you noticed that you thank
you guys no they didn't mention sales
they just don't mention theirs
good to you switch company to the hot
but they didn't check
from dawn to talk with speaking of
nintendo y'all better live stream than
nintendo direct next week
not happening that's not happening yeah
they're gonna do uh if two hours on one
character talking about how he fits the
ball in
me lately
kirby no i do not want to see kirby
sucking down stuff paul i do not want to
see none of that stuff that game is kind
of disturbing to me i don't know why you
just use that word sucking down yeah
wait a second wait a second i don't know
why you're emphasizing on it let's go
you're the one that's man
chat man i appreciate he's been a member
for
six months shout out to the lord's best
family and gaming question for jess how
did the kishi uh version 2 controller
compare to the namco mgx pro forget
mobile gaming jazz
kiss uv2 bodies
10 hour super chat from ducky always a
good time watching the show y'all keep
doing what you're doing uh dougie i
believe in the class shout out to iop
destiny glance
then we got a super chat from uh dham
thread in my country some stores are
doing families that lack knowledge with
tech dirty was selling the series s all
their do
all they done is pre-installed the
latest update and for this take take an
extra 120. yeah that's that's kind of
dirty i don't know what that's about
that's crazy we gotta find out shrimp
trap from flame oh jess corbin from iron
lords podcast interviewed iron lord god
interviewed lord cognito get him to
confirm the existence of it we got the
exclusive fawns dropped sorry
[Laughter]
you guys have been going crazy since i
started reading these super chats we
gotta find out super chat from uh thanks
one one three eight
nintendo did a turnaround with the
switch coming from the wii u poor sales
last year xbox is pulling up with
success this generation yeah it's one
the same success good point th x
uh do you see that i got it yeah red and
dog red red and black dog five hours of
chat nobody talking about jazz breaking
the news that a new project gotham
racing is coming where you can race the
batmobile love the show fellas is this
confirmed
we know something here uh it's it's
because i think was it on xbox two i
said that i thought project gotham
racing was like a batman racing game or
something oh yeah oh yeah i did listen
to that yeah yeah yeah i thought they
got the better we had to do it
i thought i thought it was it was like a
batman themed racing game or something
hilarious dude
oh shout out to heartbeats
oh that's the homie man we got a chance
to break bread with that man cool dude
man really cool dude he got the game
pass ultimate three month in nicole
y'all better snatch that up
and somebody around somebody else you
know that's good look at king he leaves
like someone already did it
shout out to forza legend
with the two dollar super chat for the
background of the dude with the
playstation suit laughing man okay well
i don't know what that means
oh yeah cause that was uh fonz fans had
the fonts back oh fought the background
yeah this is his background yeah he
laughed he laughed hungry shadia gave it
to our super we got that forza horizon 5
premium global edition y'all better get
that that's crazy that's crazy salute to
hoggy really doing it up for the
community and then we got my boy lloyd
metroid two dollar super king is capping
he plays skyward score sword stop it no
i don't look man
i actually have to skyrocket is a good
game
yeah
see what happens
what happens when you convert the
unconverted skyward sword's a good game
but the most you could chose ain't it
yeah that's all i was yeah but he
outside with us though
yeah i am outside
apollo oh sorry you got it
apollo cooper with the two awesome uh
playstation had more glow down than
madonna wow i don't know where we're
doing wow okay and then we got a hearty
shinny with the five dollar super chat
for those with game pass for his horizon
five premium add-on bundle global
appreciate it uh
for putting all the codes in the chat
yeah man that's love thanks everybody on
that let's get to these uh next topic
which is me man and uh yeah we got some
dudes man
yeah shout out to amd man shout out to
jason ronald amd fidelity fx super
resolution two so shout out to jason
ryan put the tweet it sounds like capcom
made the title
yeah super deluxe turbo
two dollar frame solo gaming wish
everyone in the chat and a panel a good
oh he's a good dude still after him so
yeah it looks like um uh gpu open shout
out they said they're very excited to
provide a fidelity fx super resolution
to xbox developers fsr2 can be found in
the most recent gdkx samples building
cross platform for xbox series x xbox
one which is interesting and windows
desktop many thanks to microsoft for the
continued collaboration then shout out
to the legendary jason ronald the beard
the wizard of xbox himself he said
excited to continue to partner with amd
and gpu open to provide the latest
techniques and graphic performance to
game developers on both xbox and pc he
said fsr2 samples are now included with
the gtxk with gdkx for xbox developers
so i want to get it get uh
actually uh jazz and monza on on this
because um judge you had the article you
know kind of also announcing this
talking about this in some level and
then also i want to get mods afterwards
for kind of breakdown like why is this
even important why should gamers care
about this technology
well it's sort of like
in the apps
i'm by no means an expert on this stuff
this gets like super mathematical and
technical when you get reductionist with
it but like at a very basic level it
uses like super sampling technology and
super sampling algorithms to sort of
um
make games that are blurry look crisper
basically so if you're running an xbox
series s game and you have to sacrifice
resolution to get better frame rate uh
super fx could uh fidelity fx sorry
could um upscale the
the resolution
using a sort of
um
a lighter a lighter computing load than
actually doing it natively so like you
you get the best of both worlds the
theory is you get the best of both
worlds you get a crisper image and you
get faster frame rate um
i uh i thought it was machine learning
but actually fidelity fx is not machine
learning um nvidia dlss which is a
similar sort of
you know type of technology that does
use machine learning but this doesn't it
uses sort of
uh some sort of upscaling algorithm i
don't know exactly how it works frankly
it's just magic that's just it's just
magic it's just imagining just they just
it's just the wizard jason
some magic stuff so um i don't actually
know what games you use on xbox series
but from what i understand there is a
bunch of them um it might be in games
that launched at 30 frames and are now
magically 60 frames like i think
chivalry maybe uses it
because i was i was kind and this is
just a complete guess because there's no
way of knowing really unless they
actually just come and tell you but
that's the point the point is that you
don't know it just looks better it looks
just runs better and all that kind of
stuff and um
and this is just another another aspect
of the
really it's it's going to help on the
series x
it's going to help us get good frame
rates and good resolution while also
using ray tracy on the series s
it's going to help us get better
visual quality while also maintaining 60
frames per second that's the theory
behind it and
the the latest version is better than
the last version
right jeff jeff grubb came in with some
some uh more intelligent ads in the
local but
fsr2 uses the motion of the previous
phone to interpolate the next frame ram
is similar to the secret source dlss
just not quite
so yeah it's sort of
it infers what the next frame should
look like based on on the last frame i
guess
and um
and xcloud works in a similar kind of
way like sometimes like when xcode lags
you'll see like you see like the
previous image sort of overlay on the
next frame it's because it's sort of
it's sort of like it sort of uses the
last image so it doesn't have to load
the same picture all the way over again
which is why fixed camera perspective
games often work bad because it doesn't
have to it's easy to interpolate
a game that has a fixed camera because a
lot of the data is in the next frame is
the same as the old one right
um
but but yeah that's basically the idea
just behind it um
and uh you know as as technology
progresses and stuff like super
resolution and we start getting deep
learning coming in because the xbox
series s and x both have like uh a
generic direct
machine learning chip on the motherboard
called direct ml which i don't even know
if they've started using yet
but a lot of these technologies are
going to sort of make the xbox series s
seem even more next gen as we get
further into the generation but when the
series xs first launched we didn't
really have many games that really ran
well on it to test but to be honest we
didn't really have many games like
during the review period right it was
basically nothing to test at all on
either console really but like the
series s even less so and um
when i went back to germany i left my
series x in england and i only had a
series s in germany for ages and even
over the course of six months your shoes
in the series s is my main console it
was surprising how many games suddenly
started getting updated from 30 frames
to 60 frames per second like chivalry
being one of them was one i remember
because i'm like oh man i can't go back
to 30 frames no especially in a game
like chivalry yeah
and then um and then one day they
updated it and then suddenly it was a
solid 1080p 60 you know so
that kind of stuff
now
so with fsr2 jazz that's something they
can implement later it doesn't need to
be at a development level right from the
start be implemented or i'm honestly not
sure i couldn't tell you that we got
mods let's get let's get let's get the
techie for mods gaming man pulling the
building what's up man i mean me and
you've been talking about it for a
little bit i mean fsr award i remember
you had an article and you were kind of
mentioning it to me and i remember also
the dlss talk during that time so like
explain to us a little bit more in
detail you know how important this tech
is
okay uh just like just mentioned it's
basically a technology that a uh boost
performance by depending on the mode
like it may be anything between
50 to like 30 20
and also obviously makes the image
sharper now the cool thing about fsr 2.0
is that it uses the previous frames the
motion vectors to actually build the
image and make it sharper right
and that's it's kind of that's kind of
cool when we talking about the games
that are running at
higher resolutions so for example if you
take um internal resolution that gpu is
rendering the game like 1600 p and
upscale or really reconstruct it to 4k
it looks nice and clean right and even
the early
samples like the death loop
i think was the first game that they
were testing
um that actually works works pretty well
and like there's hardly any difference
between like fsr 2.0 4k and native 4k
right
so fsr is actually cool when it comes to
like you know higher resolutions and and
not just boosting performance right like
you know uh now fsr 2.0 is no nothing
really new like similar techniques
already exist like unreal engine even
unreal engine 4 has a similar technique
taa reconstruction because it's kind of
similar kind of um
you know similar technology and it's it
pretty much works the same like it
reconstructs uh the image in the same
way so makes it sharper
now the problem with with fsr in my
opinion is that um because
xbox series
x and playstation 5
i mean maybe maybe
i don't want to say that they don't need
that but you know they don't need that
as much as xbox city says right right
because like a lot of people like even
even in my comment section or like when
i'm on twitter and talking with people
and they're like oh you know mods when
xbox cds is going to get that you know
upscaling technology ml up scanning
technology now we were
we were waiting for fsr it's not using
machine learning um
at all right and the problem is that it
uses previous frames
uh generated by gpu so
in in the case of xbox city says when
you've got a game that
unfortunately a lot of these games
actually drops below 1080p right so that
image like the native image is not of a
great quality so there's not much you
can actually construct from right i mean
you know that technology does you know
whatever it can but sometimes you know
our details may be missing and you are
still it's sharper better looking but
it's not as nice as like that 4k versus
sffsr4k
and that that's the same problem as with
unreal engine for example
um
reconstruction in 1080p doesn't just
doesn't really look that nice right and
that's why even though that fsr 2.0 may
be
good for some developers uh because like
you know they may not have their own
technology like there's um like if you
look at playstation for example all
these you know playstation game engines
for the most part have got their own
technology like that already
construction technique
exactly so fsr 2.0 will be no good for
them anyway because they've got their
own right it's not doing anything new
for them it may be better for like you
know developers that don't have that
just yet
and the last thing i want to say about
you know these technologies overall
is that i'm still i mean it's cool that
we've got that right and that they
improved um over
fsr 1.0
but i'm still waiting for machine
learning on consoles and we need that
desperately so especially xbox city says
right break that down as to why
the machine learning aspect really
excites you more than the kind of
reconstruction techniques
okay so
that technology is kind of similar it
obviously uses the motion vectors the
previous frames but it also the
algorithm has additional data
from the servers where you actually
building a model for
you know basically developers when
they're developing games
um they kind of
send or load samples uh to kind of let's
say it like a server right or a computer
somewhere and that computer is kind of
uh analyzing all the frames and
everything right
and these samples a lot of times are
being loaded in 8k
right so the difference between machine
learning based technology and just fsr
like like a local one is that when that
algorithm machine learning based
algorithm is trying to reconstruct our
image
well it has way more data to build it
from right
so basically stuff that on xbox city
says because it's lower resolution may
be missing because that that information
that
like maybe some leaves on the trees or
maybe some flowers far in the distance
because these things are of a very low
quality very low resolution
when after reconstruction they may be
missing but with machine learning these
small details are still going to be
there because the data is uh provided by
machine learning let's just say right so
and that's why when you look when you
watch digital foundry video about like
dls
uh in implementing pc games they
sometimes say oh man that game uh dlss
actually looks better than native
resolution right why because it
reconstructs image some at least some
i'm not saying that all of them but
sometimes it reconstructs even from
higher than 4k resolution so that's a
massive difference that's why we need
that on xbox city says no doubt and we
did hear it it is to be coming i know
that that was one of the questions solve
had for uh jason rodden when we had them
on that's another technique that solves
super excited for and i hear your point
and i want to get fawns in because i
know
fox man you've always talked you know
about the next generation consoles we've
talked about how you know 60 frames is
so important at this point we we're at a
point brother it's like we ain't trying
to go back to that filmic chess court in
gaming that tesla
we want that 60 that butter smooth all
the time and let's be honest like for
the most part the generation has
provided it but there are some
exceptions where we go man
what happened you don't say like why why
didn't i and especially like to mod's
point i'm looking at the series s right
and you know them trying to figure out
during the time we kept hearing the
tools the tools the tools and all that
good stuff so like what about this
technology like does this excite you
when you hear this kind of stuff or you
know
okay of course um you know any type of
innovation that that gets pushed and uh
pushes these games to the next level is
something that i'm all for man i mean we
come back we start from the days you
know we come from the days of like you
know being a square
and you know
you know on the screen
yeah it's it's like we've we've seen
this industry grow over the years over
the generations and i like to see that
growth continue and with this kind of
technology
uh
say you know you got you got guys like
todd howard who loved that 30 frames
filmic look right
don't disrespect the god
and and the thing is is like you know
that's one of the things that when i
look at star field i'm like okay so with
this tech you can basically have it look
like that but push that those frames up
to 60.
look at that
you're not feeling
i'm a man who wants to play
for uh high frame rate in my all my
games i don't care what it is it could
be uno i want high school
performance
i want that in every game i don't care
like some people are like i'm fine with
it in this game and i'm like no
we're not doing that that's whack okay
it really hurts i frame rates i mean
this is to me that the frame rates are
next gen i mean
because in the console space anyway i
know pc's had it all out but shut up pc
master racing time here hearing about
y'all you know your friends
alone
but disrespect
well respect
that's right you talked about we're
right about that you know frame rates
are the are king here you know and and
that's what i need and so
i'm really i'm really excited for this
and that's why i you know i i hope that
this really gets implemented into games
i hope that they the developers utilize
this because let's be honest they don't
seem to use all the tech right now that
was available since the start of the
generation with the series x
and i you know i i scratch my head over
it but then i'm thinking well maybe they
start off using you know the ps5 as a
development you know start and then they
port over to the x or something i don't
know maybe things will change now that
the x is selling well the s is selling
well and they'll start to implement this
stuff because
this is where you know a lot of people
are going to buy your games
hey hey fun you're saying that they out
here out selling these dudes and they're
not even using all the tools
they're not and i know a lot of people
hate that all the tools the tools but
it's the truth they haven't been using
all the tools for these
consoles so i'm i'm excited
i'll be more excited when i see it
finally getting implemented yeah i'll
tell you that
attitude before i give him the kid i
think he's gonna jump in on something
far he said specifically
i can't remember oh it's all good
kiss move i gotta ask you man you know
um you hear about fsr 2.0 we hear about
you know it being implemented on xbox
initially i don't know
and mods you could correct me from my
understanding fsr is open source so
theoretically it should be able to be on
playstation but we know the xbox was
designed it will be it will be the whole
the whole amd of fidelity effects
is on playstation and that will be on
playstation as well it's just
sony as always is like very hush-hush
about these kind of things so i i think
i think the only difference is that like
microsoft made it official and built
that into the with in mind right that's
that's the vibe i got software
development kit well playstation that
maybe i don't know actually we don't
know how that works on playstation
because they don't they don't disclose
yeah no nothing that's a good point it's
all built into the ssd
kickstarter
anyway they passed with it
ridiculous so kid like when you hear
about this type of technology does this
type of stuff excite you for for next
generation gaming or is it something
like you got to wait and see and then i
know we've had ray tracing discussions
with you in the past and you know as far
as the resources there like does any of
this excite you for next generation game
development
um
no i mean yeah no it excites me to know
that it's there and it's capable but i
get more excited when i hear about devs
actually using it yeah so implementation
but they said it's in the kits now jason
wrong but it'd be great for example like
you know i would like for like you know
the bethesda official twitter page like
we have partnered with amd to use ffsr
2.0 to ensure we get 60 frames per
second on starfix
i'm like that that would be extremely
like okay well like because there's
studios right i think
the tech uh that like stuff like fsr and
all this stuff that that's in these uh
that's in the xbox and stuff for will be
primed for todd howard like games he
doesn't focus on like performance and
stuff like that he wants to capture on
that fidelity and the visuals and stuff
like that and
these tools that are there they're like
okay do you
and then your tech team
they can use these other things
you know to performing you know to be a
high performance game and whatnot so
it's like it's cool to know that it
exists i just hate knowing that that
those things are there and i'll play a
game like really this is like
all this stuff that's in here you still
can't get this like what are you not
using and then i know some developers
and teams are kind of hell-bent on the
technology that they already have
in-house that does their own
interpretation and upscaling techniques
that works best for what they're trying
to target but they may not be you know
the best outcome um but some people are
just more uh you know relying on the
twos that they're using in house or
unreal so you know i feel that
i gotta say one thing to todd howard
todd howard if you're listening to this
which you know who knows it's it's the
ilp here so absolutely uh but if you're
listening to this oh todd howard if you
listen
up man we want you on the show
ain't nobody out there playing your
games for its graphics
nobody's playing your games for that
detail within your world okay we're
playing those games for those rpgs
and the the narrative oh jess says
you're wrong oh no i'm not wrong jess i
i've never looked at a a at a fallout
game or an elder scrolls no you said
somebody easy about you you said no no
no nobody is get them jess
we love the rpg elements in the game we
love the narratives we love
diving into that universe but we don't
look at those graphics and think that's
amazing we don't change that's why it's
stunning
not since white's thought
he's looking down
that way that's because tom howard feels
that way let me hear this let's just
preach no other game no other game let
you interact with every single object in
the world like every single like bullet
oh that's interaction i'm talking about
the way it looks when you pick up that
cup i'm talking about the weight
but i can touch it but that but that has
performance overheads right like if like
of course i like the outer world if you
play the other world it's 4k it's 60
it's gorgeous but everything is flat
everything's a static object it's like
ah stuck on the background but in a game
like skyrim and starfield and stuff
that every object is a real object you
know and you you shoot a rocket in a
room full of melons and the melons fly
all over the place because it's
it's the it's it's the tri the trade
through physics
yeah it's got everything
no no no i'm with you on that jess i
agree with you on those kind of details
when it comes to interaction
but nobody is playing those games for
the visuals yeah but let's be real here
i will agree with you uh i've always
been the kind of person that you know
because i'm a huge bethesda fan like
when it comes to
i expect their games to look good
but i don't expect them to be eye
gauging you know what i'm saying
but but i will say if you popped in
that that star feel and it was looking
like fallout 3 oh no you would scratch
your head like the thing about star
field though i was one of the ones who
has a bethesda fan as somebody who
played all their other games except for
fallout 76 i don't touch that game but
uh
i i love
their their games and i could tell right
away the visual jump the leap from
fallout it is a star field i i hate the
fact that so many people bagged on that
game and i'm like what's wrong for
bethesda for those developers that looks
awesome that looks awesome
and i feel you but
i said on the show multiple times i've
said we live in a age where game play
secondary thought when it comes to
revealing product and
you know i i'm i'm right there with you
i prefer gameplay over everything else
and i thought the game looked good it
just i do i do understand where people
are coming from when you look at a
next-gen only game as series x and s
game people did expect a little bit more
of a leap because this isn't just their
next game it's the first
for bethesda though developer look
developers each device it doesn't matter
what studio they all they they all focus
on different aspects uh with their games
you've got naughty dog who does great
with the mechanics but their visuals are
stunning you've got other studios like
that's what i hate when people compare
facial hair on a loy to a bethesda game
that's fast that's the that's the loud
minority that we need
well here's the thing there's also also
things like jazz was talking about that
bethesda does way better and the fact
that everything is interactive which on
the last of us too not everything is
interactive
you can't compare all these developers
they're all different they all focus on
different things and they all do
something great
and i feel you fawns but think we can
both agree that comes after the game
comes out as of right now
it is if the game looks visually
appealing that's what's going on right
sad when you say it's sad but it's just
when you see a bethesda trailer
a bethesda game doesn't translate
through trailers okay because a bethesda
game is much more than a freaking
graphics you know intensive trailer
bethesda game is all about that
narrative all about that you know and
that's something that comes out after
the game released and you can you can
show that that's what i'm saying like
we're at a positioning in the marketing
and in the the duration of of the game
where it's about what you see on the
screen not what you play like we're just
you could shut off
nonsense that's what we're hearing
really when it comes to
all that narrative about the the look of
a bethesda game the look of star field
stems from all the fanboys and you know
what the media they just
they
they decide to pull that in just to get
clicks and views so they decide to write
articles based on that stuff starfield's
ugly when in reality they know damn well
it's not ugly but they want those clicks
from these people that are putting out
there that are fanboys like i'm not as
the fans are happy with this
game saying fans are happy with the way
it looks
fawns i'm not saying that you're wrong i
know i'm saying that we live we live in
a world where people
see before they do anything with the
gang like they
a world with a lot of uh
people too that's absolutely yeah
that's fair but it's like i said like
people will look at again like look look
where a lot of people won't watch old
movies because there's no special
effects in them
there's a lot of that going around keep
in mind that
we
you know even me i i'm 30. like they
yeah they're trying with demographics
for the younger generation
you're saying things that i totally
understand my point with all this is
that i don't like developers being
compared to other developers when they
they they play they make oh i agree
totally totally different games
i'm in alignment with both of you in the
sense that yeah you know some of these
comparisons i feel are bad faith
comparison based on the the genre
and that's when to me it exposes the
intent or the fact that okay you just
told me you really don't play no man's
sky you really don't play starfield i
mean you don't play but that's the game
correct because at the end of the day we
understand the algorithms involved we
understand like jesus is saying the npc
involvement the interaction the law
system the justice system you interact
with one thing and that weight carries
over the questing the logging you know
i'm saying it's it's way more than that
but i understand your point at it the
problem with twitter which is something
that's an interesting problem too yeah
no i agree i agree and what it where it
comes down to is it's a very uh what's
that like very free-facing like what you
see immediately and i'm comparing it to
what something else i see immediately
and and that's where i think until you
play the games you see the difference
and some of it i do think is bad now in
defense there are some people who
legitimately i want to be fair there are
some people who are legitimately look at
starfield and say you know what it ain't
looking all like for me for something i
waited for a next generation and that's
fair all i'm saying is let's play the
game let's understand the scope of the
game right because the scope until you
could tell me another game that is
attempting
all of these things this game is
attempting with ship combat and collins
and thousands of planets and all this
other stuff and a full fledged quest
game of 30 to something hours then we
can have that conversation but i feel
which i said i definitely want to yeah i
understand that yeah i think the biggest
thing that we just had is one of the
reasons developers have a hard time
showing us games before it comes out
because they know that people won't take
it to that like this is an early build
this is still in development they're
going to look at that be like yo that's
the game well yeah
and to the fans credit you know whatever
you
show someone expect to get criticized on
some level two you know
they owe the right to to have that that
opinion but i do i do want to open this
up because i know we've got that's just
never no bethesda's never been one of
those that showcased well
yeah and and honestly when when you
think about their games too uh again we
go back to the whole detail aspect
you know that they really put into to
their games and the narrative and and
that doesn't translate with a trailer it
never will for them
and and i did see a lot better visuals
in in this yes there were some visuals
that were kind of pancaked like some of
those trees and stuff yeah
but
their faces their face models i thought
they looked a lot better than their
older friends they did for the people
their animations were even better than
their the other uh games were and i even
thought the lighting was really good so
i saw some improvement
they did and for the people that like
zoom in 20 times 100 to see in
inconsistencies and they're weird it's
like though those are the
those are
the small
loud minority that like we just gotta
act like they don't exist because the
moment you give them vocal opinions and
and you talk about them on shows and
stuff and like that's that's that's what
they want they want that power because
they want that acknowledgement that you
know their words meant something it's
like when i went into starfield i've
always said i want
good world building good interactions
good world immersion and like look like
the the game i've always felt like
bethesda games always looked above
average to what's going on in the
industry right now they've never looked
amazing but they've never looked hot
garbage either it's like it's something
that's like yo i could play this this
looks good but it's never anything that
you could put up to like the top game
and they'd be anything close but that's
okay because what they lack in that
fidelity they always have an everything
else
in rpg mechanics gameplay i completely
understand i want to get king in because
he's been patient kid you know when you
hear about that
when you hear about this tech you know
i'm saying the fsr2 and what it could
potentially do for resolution frame
rates and things that looks like xbox is
implementing first at least and has it
you know with the system in mind like
what does that excite you what do you
feel about this type of stuff well um i
just want to let everybody know um
microsoft has put out the mandate that
uh we all use uh fsr uh so i'm using it
right now
[Laughter]
you're utilizing though you're super
cool
yeah so i just want y'all to understand
so you use a higher resolution or
yourself and then you blacked out the
textures in the back oh that's what
happens actually crazy the world outside
is machine learning
right now
so you guys you could actually see me in
a higher
shout out to fidelity zoom
implementation of episode 2 the kicks
the collaboration i see i'm on 60 frames
per second time we outside
i'm glad that you know jason ryan on the
team putting inside the dev kits and uh
this is what i told y'all before
this is the best part about everything
it's the gift that keeps on giving
all this stuff is geared to make little
man do what little man's supposed to do
all right so if you get a 1080p uh
visual off a little man right
okay and i know you guys saying 1080p
come by you don't even got a 4k tv shut
up
you at the 1080p we already know you the
tcl dude we marketing this is marketing
101 we're going to the least common
denominator
we going to the masters at tcl did we do
it so so what they said was that they
looked at they really hit us with
assistance
yeah it's going to be paris
so the fact of the matter is this right
these dudes keep capping all this stuff
is for little man
to make because we already know the ex
could do all he's supposed to do i agree
okay do it all natty right so
everybody's been sitting there saying oh
man how can we get little man you know
to to to actually keep up well here we
go right right
don't you think king real quick that
these implements are put in for later
gen games to make sure they can always
meet the demand of the console to make
sure it comes out at 60. well i think
that all the future proofing that they
did put inside the dev kits and why the
dev kits was behind
because they were trying to make sure
that the the tools that they give to the
um their community
is actually going to stand the test of
time
you know um i'm not a developer right
and i'm not going to sit here and say oh
the developer tools for the playstation
is a whole lot easier than it is for the
xbox i don't know and i don't care what
i do know is that they have a lot more
cross-generation games and to me it's
just like okay so we maximized them and
put them up uh on um higher platform on
the playstation 5 and the playstation 4
is what they're concerned about right so
when microsoft said they was going to
support their console for two years you
dude's flipping out getting ridiculous
about it right but then playstation came
and said we're gonna support for five
years right and why because the
development tools is a whole lot
friendlier when they supporting the
playstation 4. and good whatever happens
i don't care if they get fsr i don't
care about that stuff as long as it
makes the games look better and run
better but what i think microsoft's plan
is to give little man the ability to
continue to evolve and compete with the
other consoles
right at a low resolution the resolution
looks good the frame rate looks
fantastic so if it can stay at 60 frames
per second and give you a 1080p or 1440p
image
and without you noticing what it's doing
in the background because we don't
really care
all we want is stability
at all times right
so the
what what we thought going into this
generation and microsoft is the ones
that are actually putting a foot down in
the sand because next year is the cutoff
point it's gonna be future and on you
know
and it's not gonna be uh
cross-generation games it's gonna be
getting on a lay-down type of thing and
the cloud base is gonna be for the other
stuff
little man has to be able to continue to
keep up
pace so
60 frames per second 1080p image 1440p
image if you're lucky
uh performance modes and stuff like that
in the box that's a hell of a value they
dropped the
the price of the console down like 50
bucks 250. you get it for 250 you walk
inside the door your fan taxes you out
the door
you know that you have a a machine
that's not just here for the short term
that is going to be here for the whole
duration and that whole stuff that uh
the series s is holding back
think about this that's right
the series s has tech inside the box
that allows it to compete
with the next general current gen
consoles right because it's a current
gen console the playstation 4 does not
have said tech like
right yeah we got that tech is not there
right so we're doing so good
you're not going to get an unbiased
conversation from me when it comes to
how you feel people wonder if
you wonder why when we do when we read
the super chats people love throwing out
an excellent xbox one oh yeah this is
why i came up i gave up on it
somebody is holding us back
i'm not going to say who the person is
playstation 4. but what i will say is
soon you're going to start seeing little
man compete on a level that is equal to
the current gen consoles and it's and
it's fantastic to see that they're
actually
thinking about i think all of this stuff
was thought about with little man and so
i wanted to jump in that's what yeah
that's what i want to jump in i'll make
bots quick yeah i'm i agree with pretty
much the panel here you know from a
next-gen standpoint these are the type
of things that excite me i do like
that um xbox i guess shout out to jason
around the team is that they have they
built their system with a lot of future
proofing in mind and that's the thing
that excites me you love to hear about
this so like what attic is saying later
in the generation you start to really
start to see the benefits and i love
when you go through tools
tools shout out to the tools it feels
like they built
what the ideal that it would evolve yes
they left plenty of things where it
could do anything they want to yeah and
to me that's exciting because i love
when you look back at a generation and
you look at the end of the generation
and you go whoa you know i'm saying look
how impressive this is like i remember
the end of the 360 generation and seeing
like a halo 4 and you're like yo you
know what i'm saying like this is really
impressive and that to me is when things
evolve the mature and to me that extends
the generation so you don't necessarily
have to rush out you know for the new
cars we know another console most likely
generation will start but to me that
extends the life of it what i'm hearing
yes kate i know how you guys it's over
yes yes they're doing this fight right
now with one hand
so when when
i see
y'all guys don't really get it when i
say it's over last playstation you're
going to be an app later
i'm telling you when the hand when the
constraints is off yes
and they say all right give them
everything we got
take that cloud
off and put it out there we no longer in
beta we outside now when they say we
outside when when you start seeing
commercials say xcloud is outside that's
normal that's the code that's order 66.
that's that's it okay that's all the 66.
they gonna tell jazz you're gonna see
it's gonna be one tweet
yes and it's gonna say it has begun
and y'all gonna see all the jedi get
rounded up
it is gonna happen and you go
okay
shut up
hold up
we got to make this fun king
okay the order is 6016. who who's obi
who's obi-wan who's living by my hair by
by a lamb mine
[Laughter]
i told
for all those people in the know in the
background okay
it's gonna be a cryptic it's gonna be a
tweet you're gonna see it it's all gonna
come from jeff yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
first of all if you played any of the uh
battlefield games i mean uh you all know
that this different size every story man
we you know sometimes
i'm going to throw this out there man uh
phil spencer is the emperor you're darth
vader
ridiculous
anyway like i was saying before we broke
into star wars references
look you know according to
i agree with the the the series s um
being the fact because i do think they
envisioned that as the top seller i
think that was part of the design in
mind for them
all those playstation dudes that was a
hundred dollars cheaper and you're not
gonna cap i know you dude you walked in
the store you saw 500 versus four and
you said i don't want that i want debt
and i know how it went down so we got
you boxed in right now it's cheaper
and that's why it's selling and y'all
can't take it away from me because i
told you it was gonna happen yeah i'm
sorry thank you i do apologize this is a
very good day yes yes thank you look at
that yes
because like i mean i i know that may
that may not be the best metric for
no it's the amazing metric we're not
gonna act like it's not in america
no no no no okay
i'm talking about the the thing that i'm
i'm i'm about to say go for it because
there's this youtube channel i think
they
he's called like aj gaming something
like that he does these like benchmarks
on the consoles as well okay and like if
you look at the um digital foundry and
many other they show frames and they
talk about resolution but this guy
in particular he shows the power usage
as well
and there's always obviously a power
limit on these chips and that kind of
stuff but obviously the
the more you tap into the all the
resources of the chip the more the more
power you use right and
like
i think that was years five or something
was using like 220 watts or something
like that you know during like normal
gameplay gamepl
most games right now and that was like
first part of the game they said that
they are using a lot of these like
negation architecture already they're
like they were like playing with it yeah
not to a full extent but that game was
using like 220 or close watts
during the gameplay most games these
days like when he tests these games are
running around
160 70 and stuff so that you know that
goes to show that a lot of stuff that is
that is in that chip is still not being
fully used right
uh so like this and you know funny
enough like xbox is xbox city says is
using like you know 60 or what's and
something like that so i know that it's
not the best metric per se but it just
goes to show that a lot of
small components that are built you know
like to really uh like
boost all these games and that kind of
stuff are not like even used at all at
all yeah you gotta stop giving me this
ammo oh god this is what i'm talking
about see he just gave me another bullet
for the chamber he just told me
that little man ain't even using all
so little man is in the gym doing one
arm 90 pound curls and he's looking over
and he's only at 60 hertz and he's like
imagine i really use all my power
has so many
more things in the wings like they have
they have exclusivity
to all the open ai machine learning
stuff
like they invested a billion dollars
into open ai
and which is why like um github and
visual code now you can ask a robot to
finish your code executions for you you
know stuff like this is going to speed
up the pace of development exponentially
but you'll be able to ask ai like to
animate stuff for you and generate art
for you and generate assets like it's
still going to be
it's still going to be like most stuff's
going to be handcrafted right yeah but
like if you can free up a developer from
having to animate a rat or something or
ride that ai for some background mob or
something that doesn't really matter but
add some ambience it's going to really
ramp up the pace of development and
microsoft has exclusive rights to
commercial applications for everything
that open ai is developing
so you know
what are you doing here what are you
doing you're bringing mad cookies for me
to eat and you just told me microsoft is
skynet
the chat has requests that you can't
talk unless you sound like darth vader i
i'm just uh i'm the person past
so someone said that you're
you're emperor palliative if phil
spencer
[Laughter]
said yes it's going according to plan
oh yeah so yeah look it's impressive you
know it's impressive stuff i like to say
i love future proofing i want to shout
out pc gaming they had a good point they
said that um i believe rdna 2 excited is
running um fsr2 better than other gpu
architectures and that's something again
microsoft had the foresight to really
you know go with their system and i love
that rdna too
yes that's inside the boxes right
yes
so
here we go
[Music]
playstation five is using our dna three
remember oh yeah remember
i put them on top of each other and duct
tape them
again if you put one on the other that's
going to be like our dna five already
but you can't have two you can't have
two of those fast ssds together in the
same room
yes so now that we're done with that oh
sorry in the playstation's architecture
yeah look you know my main thing and as
far as the test is one of the main
things that excites me about the next
generation when it was announced was the
ray tracer thing but when i started to
learn more about it and see how much of
a resource hog it is it really turned me
off because i'm like damn when you see
like with ray tracing on and you see
where the frames go and you know far as
how our face does when the frames go so
i was just like oh so now when i hear
about this and i know machine learning
is not implemented yet and that's
something else is additional but when i
hear about tech like this this excites
me to see the adoption rate is
impressive like bob said we see with
death loop in the games that already
have fsr 1.0 and from my understanding
it's it's a pretty easy implementation
you said def loop has fsr 1.0 mm-hmm so
by the time you know
button pc 2.0 on pc
microsoft console yes it'll have the 2.0
yes and theoretically yes yes
with everything else built okay
i'm just i'm just i'm just being
absolutely okay you know what you know
what kk like you don't go with my
analogy
microsoft by building the death star
they are and they're going to hear it's
this is not a moon
ridiculous fire
anyway so look it's impressive you know
like i said i just now my main thing is
for the older games that miss the 60
frames per second target particularly on
little man that'd be cool if those go
back and implement it yeah and that's it
exciting tech i can't wait for the
future and i'm glad that they had this
in mind with the text so i am going to
move on
because king's never going to stop um
god of war ragnarok man or we got super
chat's ready to get worse
yeah we got super chats right all right
let's go
all right so guy uh oh it does look like
we could just be looking at the chat
king you're gonna you're gonna read his
history
he's super chat oh he back when we get
to oh okay yeah okay
he gave him his allowance for the week
the gave his allowance for them
you got to find out street trap from
doughnut talking skyward sword is the
second best 3d zelda behind breath of
the wild don't at me uh i wouldn't go
that i actually think it's better than
breath of the wild oh it's just me wow
gotta find out captain
logan uh xbox
power pushing the native 4ks the a b
news pushing the idaho that native fork
out isn't the end goal of fps is the
real king
uh we actually have a a member okay uh
chat so definitely yeah i've been a
member for three months shout out to the
lords and guests perfect podcast to
listen to our work on the lord's day
have a blessed day salute
then we have another chat uh
another chat
12 months by
dragon heart yobe
the lessons
uh
hashtag peace love life to the lords
keep up the great work uh at fawns
welcome back brother glad to see that
smile again man we happy to see you
don't call it thank you
don't call it a comeback you all know
iop is taking over right no just wait oh
salute thank you could you please hit
the like button though
because your vegas take over with the
likes
the great xbox podcast on the internet
top five dead or alive and that's just
off
oh
no he don't we better leave him alone
he's keeping that bid to go ragnarok
come out so he's gonna hit the floor
we had a nice super chat from the dawn
cg uh c uh jg the general audience just
wants a cool looking game via a trailer
i feel like it's very easy to get out of
touch with the average person with tech
and smaller details then we gotta fight
off the screenshot from switch mitch
skates
uh i don't know i don't care uh someone
damn
from software that fps i need 60 frames
on eldon ring on the series x i thought
it was 60 frames yeah it is yeah it is
i i don't know what you playing it's
like elderly
he got a tcl
that's the problem
he reverse variable ratio
he's probably playing
he's probably playing uh bloodborne on
playstation doesn't hurt
um so then we got a
super chat from gamer by choice
five dollars so xbox was thanos with the
snap and order 66 with the empire aren't
both of these evil and didn't they lose
xbox do better he got a point there they
do lose in that that scenario but it
takes them it takes them decades and
generations to lose so we got a five
dollar super cat from free r kelly
king it don't matter nobody playing xbox
really
really r kelly
six thousand new people are playing xbox
shout out to my people out japan
rocking your snot box
get back in the yard
we got a two dollar sweep shot from
flight this is an iop classic episode
loving a fella absolutely that's all we
got all right we all caught up all right
cool let's
yeah it's your topic man a lot of room
is going around the snitch is back
talking about god of war
first off i i don't even know exactly
how we want to cause this this
for those who don't know we got a real
playstation insider man we got a real
one really we don't got fake ones
uh you know
the crazy part is he
he's been very accurate even with xbox
stuff and he posted a
a a picture a gif that said god of war
and it had numbers at the bottom he said
one one one zero zero zero
uh so i'm kind of curious what you guys
so
first off there's supposed to be a
a state of play next week on thursday
dedicated to uh to yeah to god of war uh
keep in mind that uh you know nothing's
confirmed but at this point if the great
snitch says it it's it's it's it's
accurate
yeah uh so i i want to go to king first
king looks like uh looks like that god
of war might come out this year
this is where really it's coming out
for all you guys waiting and next week i
might be wrong but for today i'm going
to give you hayachi face
[Laughter]
and and when next week comes and they
give you a state of play
or
ragnarok dlc that's coming out next year
when they when they tell you you gotta
pay fifty dollars more for the car
grant to pays more um
and you guys and they said oh we gave
another patch to fix up for
horizon forbidden west
y'all still sitting there looking for
that date and they say one one two zero
two three and it's next year
well according to the stitch uh whatever
i don't care what the snitch is saying
it's this bit on fire i don't care
so right now i've been on fire i'm 97
right
hey snitch i don't believe you and next
week y'all got to show me you got to
take that off fawns that's creepy
that's exactly what kratos gonna look
like
they always do the bait and switch with
these dudes they give a day to be like
yo yeah we coming now and then right
before us about the launch we had
unforeseen situations happening
and we're gonna need a four-month layoff
are you gonna pull up with us that you
and then you'll still go get it and
you're gonna still have a day one patch
i don't care you're not getting it
you're gonna be just like me dry this
year
wow we all gonna be drinking sand
together
your feeling on what the relationship i
am i am i don't care if we don't have no
gains you ain't got no gains
and you know what the energy is good in
the room
i like how i feel we got game pass i
don't know how you gonna survive so i i
got like
just just to clarify king i personally
would want god war to come out this year
i don't want
why you don't want a good game to come
out if i can't eat in my restaurant i
want nobody eating either
why they can't have big games you know
what it is you want to sit here and play
that kumbaya stuff oh you know we it's
great for gaming no it ain't great for
me next year i'm able
jazz i want a body to snitch
oh king k i got a question like real on
this series
if we talk him from like the perspective
of you know xbox uh coverage versus
playstation coverage would it make more
sense for playstation to release a game
not
around star field or fall they don't
ever they always fall over their feet
they did that same thing on horizon they
get their hubris and in their head they
they think they rise
hold on we got another trusted insider
man lord tom henderson's in chat
god of war is this
year okay someone's knees is we'll be
gone
i'm a body you too um
tom is the legend you're not that tom
tom i'm body and youtube um
this is i'm putting myself out there
okay i'm about to go oh yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah you you are you
put your knees on this are you from the
left
[Music]
me and you see this is this this is the
problem
i lose i'm just gonna be like whatever
the weight of this is gonna lean on you
type heavy
because that's fine
for the rest of the year remember what i
did to your man jay barry hey you you
know what
so when you get down on your knees all
that all that protein and calories that
you save can go to your cartilage and
your knees
[Laughter]
anyway so look
and there's no god of war and you're
sitting there with high itchy face i'm
just gonna look over at you i'm not even
gonna say nothing i'm just gonna look
over at you and be like i'm not
[Laughter]
war comes out this year next year or
next year okay so you say kick stays
next year yeah
this year okay it's gonna get
slaughtered by starfield
st it's gonna come out and star feel
gonna come out and body yeah i'm down
with that i'm away with all that smoke
hold it here we go this is this you
heard it here first this is the easiest
been the knees i've ever had
oh hold on
hold on i gotta break protocol tom
patterson with the 20-pound super chat
if it's 20 22 you shave that blur bone
fluff off your face king if it's 20 23
hold on tom henderson will donate 500
dollars to the super chat let's go
let's go
first of all first of all
you don't even know who the hell that is
you try to confirm that's not true i
said we got to keep that about we don't
we don't care chomp chomp the iop
account and say it's me tom what i would
want right and i want you to do it live
on it
all right
i want you to shave your whole face
eyebrows and all right all right so
okay i'm down with all of that you won't
go after the bed i want to go after your
eyebrows i want you out here with the
smooth face i want you when you sweat
and get in your eyes and you remember me
that's what i'm going for i'm going for
bald eyebrows tops so so so so beard
versus eyebrows
i want his eyebrows for me
can we keep the 500 in
i want his eyebrows okay so it's the
eyebrows
versus the beard tom henderson do you
bend the knee back between lord king
david and eyebrow versus eyebrows versus
baby
he ain't
he's doing another one you did nothing
he said twenty dollars he said i'm out
peace i don't know what that means
i don't know what that means about peace
does that mean
cause he know his eyebrows is up for
sale
it's different when you tell a dude give
me your eyebrows
oh you scared him that's what he did
you scared him out of it okay that's
what you say well when you tell a dude i
want your eyebrows see could you imagine
this muscle face dude walking down the
street with a muscle face with no
eyebrows and it's hot outside get you in
the middle of the summer it's hot and
the sweat get in your eyes and it burns
and you're gonna remember me every time
you did it you can remember the day you
crossed king and i listen i want your
eyebrows regardless i'm still all in i
don't care if you run i'm coming for you
tom i want your eyebrows like your baby
eyebrows was too far for time so we'll
see we're going for eyebrows you want to
go for bear i'm going to see
500 to shave his eye
he's like i got people to see
baby tom don't want that don't want to
do that respect respected tom the legend
this hilarious okay brendan lee broke
out randomly um
lord fox man um
where you at with this uh god of war the
snitch is saying
in binary
the 30th
i still say tom's willing we still do
the 500 versus your beard key
i don't care about the money i want his
eyebrows he ain't going to give you his
eyebrows live on tv i want to shave me
i don't want no residue
i can't continue
kate don't want to shave that beer
that's what it is listen i'ma shade a
bit no he's putting the light on we go
for the eyebrows though
i want your skin your eyebrows i want it
to be shown and this is how you know who
your real friends are who want to take a
picture with you with your eyebrows
you're ridiculous i wouldn't take a
picture with you guys with your eyebrows
what do you think about this sir
well i i think the snitch is right i
think uh we'll see something on the 30th
and uh it'll definitely be a release
date and i think it'll be
laughing he's still here
i think it'll be 11 11 20 22. i i think
they're going to use that date
i mean it would be kind of a shame if
they didn't at this point because
honestly that would be the biggest like
you know what move
oh they do it on on starfield's initial
dates
exactly 11 11 22.
i was if i was playstation i'd be that
petty
you know i would just smack king all in
the mouth on your day
[Music]
them to do all types of wild stuff it
just never happened
no it hasn't but i mean what what date
are they gonna choose i mean this this
kind of makes sense too in the fact that
starfield is no longer coming out
it it it makes sense
because october's got a few games coming
out
and i'm not saying it would compete with
god of war but hey there's stuff there
but in november there's really nothing
there
this is a hot one look lord jazz at the
playstation insider
is just still here did he developers i
don't see just no more hopefully just
come back maybe step away for a little
bit but until jess comes back lord mods
man what do you feel about this uh god
of war ragnarok do you think the snitch
might be onto something to stay to play
this year you're with king that yeah not
thinking it's coming
yeah i mean he he was right
many times before so why not this time
around right so
yeah i mean it looks like the you know
uh looks like they will show god of war
on 30th and
who knows maybe they will announce their
release date for this year who knows
right i mean you know
if if um you know if they if that game
is really coming out this year they
really need to start like talking about
it showing it promoting it and that kind
of stuff now
um you know it's actually interesting
that like um phones mentioned in
mentioned um
november but uh it's um
i'm kind of like that would be
interesting because like i mean maybe
unusual even for playstation because
when was the last time they released any
big title
like even like in november yo you took
my point damn because like yeah i mean
like because the thing is like they were
and
when when call of duty is coming out is
it the problem november
yeah so
i don't know like
i don't necessarily okay i i don't
necessarily agree with phones on the
release date so 11 11
um
maybe
september oh
i mean this is gonna happen
it's too soon here's the thing usually
even sony
i mean
even sony they delay games all the time
so announcements mean nothing but
you have to announce games at least a
few months out before they drop i mean
you have to start the marketing hype and
everything like that that's just uh
business 101 i don't see them saying hey
you know on the 30th next week saying
hey it comes out in two months i think
that's too early
i i think they have to put it out there
at least let me let me ask you this to
mod's point though fonz like really one
thing that i kind of do sign with mods
on is that they like to be part of the
video game awards discussion they want
their games to be celebrated
we've heard like internally they like to
line it up and november's really cutting
it you know what i'm saying you know
what though it's cutting it but at the
same time you know the kiwis what
they're all about bro come on come on
are we really doing this every sony game
pretty much gets you know a nod but i
know where you go i'm not go i know
where you go i know what you're doing
this isn't this isn't a big huge like
rpg that you have to spend 75 hours on
okay some people are gonna get through
through this pretty quickly especially
journalists and stuff they're gonna have
their your eights nines tens
so you think november still makes that
cut off to be included in the game award
for the god of war if it's unless
what about call of duty i mean it's it's
it's uh they still got marketing rights
for that so they will be pushing a lot
of consoles thanks to call of duty so
would that make sense to release another
banger around at that time
i i think it would really affect
playstation exclusives like that not not
something to the effect of god of war
anyway let's see let's see if it happens
let's
let them go day and date with that let's
see what happens
i mean cod is always going to you know
tom henderson still hit costa
october
it would still align with you uh fines
that
it would it wouldn't it wouldn't
conflict
october yeah it could be october but i'm
just saying i'm petty if i was
playstation 11
look i like to see competition that's
what i'm actually a gamer
tom you in that chat man you in that
chat do you and your and your expertise
think they would drop that on 11 11. i'm
curious what tom got yeah let's all get
that but while we're doing that now
let's finish your thought and then i
gotta get jeff
uh i'm i'm just saying that like i just
don't
i mean like
i have no like obviously ins inside the
knowledge on this i just i just think
that like you know uh god of war would
may i mean if co if call of duty wasn't
um being promoted by you know sony if
they haven't had
marketing rights for call of duty maybe
that would be a different story but like
you know pushing one game after the
other even though call of duty is not
different type an exclusive but they you
know when they advertise it they make it
like hey it's on playstation only and
that kind of stuff so you know would you
want to
uh have you know interest taken away
from their game i just i just don't feel
it no fair enough call of duty is
supposed to come out in october end of
october yeah shout out a lot of time he
said he doesn't have no idea to answer
your question addict and he's laughing
and then he said mid november will be
consistent with some marketing plans
though lord jazz man i know you're not
necessarily you know involved with the
playstation ecosystem as much but you
know what do you think about this
potential rumor from the snitch in 11 11
and well not maybe june 30th for the
state of play you know what do you think
jess
i'll see you back
just still muted um but it is
what do i think yes
i think uh
great
[Laughter]
all right so put it this way in xbox
terms because i know you don't really
mess with it
do you think do you i know you don't
care i know you don't but my question is
like do you think if let's say he's 11
11
isn't that a little bit disrespectful
i think it's i think it's just funny you
know because if like
if they if they sort of pull something
that petty
it's going to look very silly in the
next five years when they start getting
completely obliterated oh
when he said he hasn't begun i told you
he on my time
i told you listen you're just it's true
yes before we go i don't think that do
something in this pay because it's just
it's just going to end up looking silly
so 11 11
if they're picking that date they're
picking it because they think it's a
good day
personally i don't think it'd be no they
pick eleven eleven it's like probably
like personal that's if they pick eleven
eleven that's pettiness yeah
that's old playstation we talk about jim
here jim not looking at
imagine somebody from playstation
announcing that uh that game coming out
on 11 11 and they will say just that it
just works
they have a brown leather when they say
it oh boy it'd be crazy right and
imagine phil coming out saying the deal
is done with activision and no more call
of duty for you it just feel good it
just felt right
it just feels like
you looking he looked you in your face
to say sue me
kiss move real quick oh god of war man
never love him
11 11 the snitch is outside that level
of june 30th state of the ruby's state
of play i i think state of play happens
june 30th with um god of war
um
but i think it um
the only space forward to release
honestly this year would be november so
11 11 i'd be like yo that's kind of just
kind of wrong um but it is what it is
microsoft didn't oh it doesn't own the
date it was in the face
but i think we get an extended stated
play just for them to tell us is
releasing like february 4th or something
like that oh oh oh so you think they
might get the what what oh king said we
you know we show we tell you it's coming
but we needed more development time and
then a later date they did
i don't think a delay will happen
because corey barlow keeps replying to
people saying it's not coming out this
year and he's like oh really you know
he's off yeah he's outside corey
baldwin's outside yeah
yeah we got to see all right interesting
reuse assets it better be
a long time ago
that's all i got what happened yeah i
got it i got you i got you so i said
attic and then we forget about it on
this topic
yeah i
i've always been very vocal about unless
they're gonna break their november thing
that it wasn't coming out this year but
you know i kind of been pulling away
from that because
these dabs are just too out there like
if if one person breaks like you know
silence and they didn't and that game
wasn't coming out this year i feel like
sony would tighten the leash on everyone
else so fast
but it's just like we've had an art
director an art designer say we've had
corley barlog might as well be coming
out here saying it we got marketing for
accessibility stuff we got leaked rumors
we got the stitch singing what else got
to happen does someone got to leak the
game
well the snitch in fairness is say
the date in binary for the state of play
but not necessarily the date for the
game itself but but you you got to like
put them together like you got to snitch
say when the state of play is and then
you got corey barlog making fun of
people saying it's not coming out this
year
you got multiple people working for uh
saint monica whatever their name is
sony santa monica
whatever whatever
that's where the god of war coming from
saint monica
you got multiple people saying that it's
coming out to share like look like i
hope it comes out this year because this
this i do i'm dying from i want i want
popeye biscuits for everybody through
the hell with it
to next year just like me
pop out biscuits oh real
the real question is is it coming to pc
he's gonna hit the deck
as hell yeah that's what that's gonna be
that's what it's about on the 30th
they're gonna tell you it's coming to pc
[Music]
oh she's ridiculous well courtney thomas
this didn't say state of play he says
something else
we will see we'll see we'll see like my
thing is man after all this i guess i'm
gonna have to stream that state of play
now because if the release dates at the
end yeah like we we got all this all in
the livestream
we're probably gonna i will be streaming
that i'll be right back
i'll try to stay laughing i'll try to
sleep
if anything me and king will be there
watching that and i want everybody
that's inside the chat i want y'all to
clip it i want you to clip the reaction
i want you to clip everything it's going
to be probably one of my greatest
crowning achievements that y'all see and
i'm calling my shot i'm like babe roof
i'm pointing to the upper room and it's
about to go out the park and i'm telling
you guys when it happens
y'all gonna put some respect on my wow
when this release date is this year this
man gonna do some of the biggest
reaching
we'll see we'll see what happens if it
does come out the the only question i
have is can eldon rings title for god oh
give me the empty challenge if it does
come up that would be interesting yeah
it's it's it's
i don't care god of war comes out like i
just don't see nothing beat out and ring
unless
it's like crazy could they fix it
according to justin them only rule that
game will have came out too late in
order to be in for contention
but according to funds they said uh i
mean that jeff might make
yeah
i don't see him doing it though if it's
too far into november
i i mean if it's like they might release
it the day because nah because don't you
remember when they weren't allowing uh i
forgot the game they said the cutoff was
the 19th
but they were getting about the star
wars
yeah but they were giving people uh that
were voting on it uh their votes on the
fourth or something so it didn't really
make sense right when the game came out
like on the 10th um but here in this
situation oh that they'll let that slide
in trust me the war is going to get
passed up that gang gonna make it it's
gonna come out next year so i can win
the game of the year
i just personally feel like when it
comes to that particular game
they did their change up once you know
they i it's like breath of the wild
breath of the wild changed up the zelda
for me but god of war changes up its
formula you're right you only can do
that like that moving the mountains one
time
like now when you play the new bottle
war and the new breath of the wild
there's going to be newer stuff but it's
not going to be the same as changing the
formula that magically odin
just got the change in the formula thing
like yep i just unless god of war is
magnificent
i don't see it touching out in rings i i
agree a hundred percent with everything
you said addict i've been saying
i don't think i don't see oh that's why
i was hoping
no god of war and starfield both came
out because i feel like um god of war
ragnarok will be more of the same of
2018 yeah just with a few extra
characters a little bit more snow oh
i don't i don't think that's going to be
good enough to have forward to repeat
game of the year because if that's the
case and that's just not right it's the
same thing with uh horizon forbidden
west for me it's just more the same you
know and that's not a bad thing with god
of war i loved god of war
and i want to play more of the same but
that magic of that first real change in
the series and everything that's gone
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
that kind of feel like oh my god i can't
wait to do this or that or
i wonder what's going to happen next
because you already know like
you're going to be the mechanics are
pretty much the same the game plays the
same thing i don't think it's
disrespectful it's it's just fast it's
just obvious it's not going to be the
same in that regard yeah so i would
if if if i were to put like i would i i
god one might not even hit a 90 in
metacritic oh my god
no i i think it will oh my god
i don't think people realized how much
of like a curve god of war and breath of
the wild got for that changing [ __ ] up
i don't know because because when you
talk when you start making sequels
people what's the number one thing that
it just feels like gears it just feels
like aliens exactly
like you're gonna have a lot of this god
of war thing going on it just feels like
god award 2018. it's not that it's a bad
game it's just more of the same like i
get so addicted to
so you you're not going to be impressed
huh
no i didn't say that i just said i see
people saying those things when they're
reviewing the game yeah like because
it crosses different facts
speaking facts because uh addict did say
and i and i agree with them that if this
story if this game play is just out of
this world it's of course you got to
give it its props
it's got to be
spectacular to beat elden ring at this
point this year
i agree with that i mean i'm just saying
like we we don't know
the the premise yet we have that
a lot it's a great game regardless
we have seen game play so it is pretty
much confirmed it's pretty much on the
same engine the previous same assets so
that hasn't changed accidents carried
over they did say it's not a trilogy so
i'm curious to find out how they're
going to
resolve all of this nordic mythology
when you saw odin live thor left like
giving you all the dlc that they were
supposed to give you the first time this
is what this is god ragnarok dlc oh i
just want people to clip this this part
i just want to go to asgard
can't i get asgardly
[Music]
i know what happens when they come
outside i know what happens i know what
the zeitgeist do with it
and
i'll tell you right now that when boys
come outside at 11 11
it's gonna be different we said that the
same joint
horizon broken and it did work
we got to stop this there's nothing
wrong with horizontal
you can make an argument the horizon
forbidden west came out
it did it did good but it didn't really
raise them i agree
because the mistake because it was more
of horizon in a different game with a
different scenario
was horizon zero down
bugs the bugs was crazy like i was
yeah with a lot with
saying the oldest i'm not gonna lie but
like i have forbidden west and like i
love zero down i still can't get into
forbidden west like
that it might not be for you and i get
that all i'm saying is that game is a
technical marvel it looks phenomenal it
looks fantastic a lot of people love the
game and 13 loved it and
to me the only reason why and again
that's one therefore is that
west i can't talk today
i can't tell but if i do that other
people is old
i've been trying for like a whole hour
can't get them off
yeah get them all but that's good it's
all good but like i said all i'm saying
is the proximity to uh elder ring
really really hurt that game if that
game wasn't next to that i think we'd be
talking different it's really a
phenomenal looking game that's all i'm
saying y'all being wild disrespectful to
god what i just want to see this to say
if it come out this year i just want to
see
this clip i don't know what the
metacritic do and what the zeitgeist do
and we gonna revisit this conversation i
don't believe it being disrespectful i
see it being like when halo infinite
came out i got a lot working against it
and just no like
when a game comes out like we're
speaking it's just it's it's facts it's
not a new engine you look at the game it
does look like 2018 i mean we're not
going to say that's a bad thing 2018
looked amazing but it does look similar
to it like it's just speaking stuff
that's going on i hope they blow my
socks off i have my socks on
everything
no i was saying i was using that as an
analogy comparing the situations when uh
when when halo infinite came out you
know we com we were saying the hype that
was coming out the the issues it was
having up to that point we were saying
you know what what the expectation was
coming up to the release date that's why
i was talking strictly from a standpoint
of could it be eldon ring in game of the
year and i just don't think it could no
and that and that's fair all i'm saying
is the elderly ring thing i'm with you i
i think elderly has too much
goal for it to the throne i'm with you
out there i just don't i think i don't
realize what's about to happen if that
game drops this year what's going to
happen to the zeitgeist and what it the
effect it will do and how impressed
people will be with a corey ball game
i'm telling you that's just what i mean
i don't
no one's fighting that we're just
fighting that it got that that umph when
the first went when it came out in 2018
because they revolved everything right
and we're just saying when it comes to
this year eldon ring got that and i
don't think that
from the new perspective but all i'm
saying in fairness we haven't seen
everything that ragnarok could do either
that's all i'm saying let's see the
whole thing and then we'll judge but
we'll see yeah let's move on let's move
on let's get the last joint and then he
said he got no credit i'm done anyway
the chat is stupid let's move oh we got
the super chat so we're going to just
bump into the last one at it what are we
doing
uh let's just bump it up to the last one
all right so this is king's original
topic before the um the sales news and
this literally jumped off let me get it
lined up for him by all shout out to
forbes man forbes had an article that
caught kings interest
and pretty much it says microsoft is
leaving playstation nintendo behind even
without starfield and he pretty much the
gist of it is talking about how game
pass is microsoft's you know kind of ace
in the hole and then combine that with
uh streaming as a whole like the overall
strategy of microsoft is in his opinion
shout out to eric kane on the winning
formula that he feels that that
to king's point that that sony and
nintendo can't compete with that long
term so sony i mean sorry so kig this is
your topic you know you just clearly
resonated with you so like what do you
feel yeah about this
so
before i knew that we had fawns coming
on and we had kids move showing up i
knew we had uh mods and we had jets
right so immediately in the chat i put
uh queensbridge finest
i put uh
mauve deep
nahs
you know queensbridge and i and i knew
i knew my brothers would not let me down
i swear to god i knew
marge was going to come with the
technical
and i knew jazz was going to come with
the informational
and you know combined i was going to
bring the witty
and it was going to form into exactly
what it formed into it thank you i do
appreciate you guys but this topic was
the original topic before i got to the
you know
can i get a lockhart please
right for a little bit gave it to the
scene this this topic is crazy because
forbes
is talking about
the strategy that microsoft is doing and
it's leaving his competitors behind
because actually the competitors have
gotten the game late game pass is
actually the platform now playstation
has been there first it's just been like
a side project a little failed thing
they didn't actually strategize
right so what they did was they took a
thing that you like and it took
something that you didn't like and it
combined it rebranded it and hopefully
it sells a lot of stuff is missing they
got to get their legs well it seems like
microsoft has gotten their legs and it
seems like forbes has taken notice to it
and
if people are in the market and knows
how money works and trends work
forbes is predicting the demise of the
other two
this is the opinion of one forbes writer
let's be clear
i love i love what he wrote
i i'm extrapolating
what i read
his new favorite writer yes his new book
eric casey
definitely on kids favorite list
beautiful beautiful eloquently wrote it
he laid down the format in which the
situation spelled doom for the other
ones
i
listen i i i just want you know to
acknowledge the fact that microsoft has
a real bonafide strategy now
you know before we really couldn't see
the strategies before and exactly what
they're doing now even from from from a
hardware standpoint to a software
standpoint
they have a lot of the bases covered
that we talked about in the past and for
forbes to look over and say that they
see something completely different with
microsoft and their strategy and trying
to show their strategy going forward i
think they're on to something and i just
wanted to bring that to the room uh to
say that we're not dealing with the same
microsoft from before i know jazz know
that i know mods know that i know uh
fawns know that and everybody else knows
that here but i just wanted to get
everybody's outlook on it
anybody read the article yeah absolutely
and and to give additional context to
what you're saying he also said you know
now with xbox revealing that the samsung
smart tvs will now support game pass
cloud gaming without even owning an xbox
so pretty much the reason why i get i
think what your alignment is because the
system without the box so to speak right
and simply playing your xbox controller
with your tv for a monthly fee rather
than spending hundreds of dollars on a
console and you know this this future
that can get more gamers in so let's get
jazz in um jazz you know i don't know if
you got a chance to see the article but
just even if you didn't your overall
thoughts is do you agree with king like
this is the winning strategy that the
others the other twos can't necessarily
compete with microsoft in this space
i think he's like we've been saying for
years at this point that microsoft
doesn't even see sony nintendo's
competition they really don't that's not
that's not that's not a console thing
it's not a console thing it's not it's
not it's not like hyperbole they don't
they're looking at tencent they're
looking at
tech companies you know they're looking
at like what do we need to do to protect
our business against amazon what do we
need to do to protect our business
against this and that and it's not just
about
gaming it's about developer tools it's
about technology it's about r d it's
about all this sort of stuff you know um
it's about cloud services and and gaming
sort of it feeds into that as a sort of
part of a more comprehensive cohesive
strategy
what the gaming business is to microsoft
is just completely different to
playstation player station only up until
recently were just they were just
contented with um
having a
console
business basically it's only recently
that sony started thinking like oh
actually maybe we should put our games
on pc you know and
we all knew they would do it because
they were just leaving free money on the
table as soon as microsoft started doing
it sony had to do it they had to do it
and eventually they will do day and date
games too oh they will
i that they just have to because they're
leaving money on the table the way that
like
horizon forbidden west
that didn't launch into pc completely
killed its buzz because it launched up
against eldon ring which was on pc
nobody was talking about horizon zero
the one after a week they were talking
about old and ring and i know because i
could see i can see our network's
traffic at future you know
i i can see i can see our website's
traffic and
there was no traffic on horizon
forbidden west whatsoever everyone just
went all over to elder marine
so you know
uh all this sort of console war bubble
stuff which is you know fun fun to go
back and forth with on on twitter and
all that stuff it's it's utterly
it couldn't be less relevant it couldn't
be less it couldn't possibly be less
relevant the console install base
combining sony nintendo and microsoft
just talking about console game cells
it's minuscule compared to like
what really drives this industry you
know and um even jim ryan said that
absolutely i'm sorry mm-hmm i think i
know it's
which is why microsoft's
key performance indicator for um
for their for their gaming business is
users it's not revenue it's not console
sales
it's users it's like and so for them
they think about it in a very different
way
um
they think about it like
uh
where can we find the users you know
we're going to make it as easy as
possible for people to access our
ecosystem whether they're on the phone
whether or not a tv
whether they're just playing a game that
lets you sign in with a microsoft
account for them that's a user you know
solitaire
has like
solitaire has the second biggest monthly
act of users behind minecraft you know
a lot a lot of people realize that and
that's
that's how microsoft is able to be the
third biggest gaming company despite not
having you know a particularly large
presence on mobile or a particularly
large you know the the smallest slice of
the console part you know
but they're they're growing it and they
they're growing it out
and um by spreading across to everything
right
and um
there's someone in chat saying windows
central doesn't get forbidden west
traffic what surprised jazz and it's
like yeah
i talked about future
you know games radar
and uh tech radar and pc gamer they're
all part of our network you know
jesus stop talking about stuff you don't
know
the crap
he did a crazy flex on you right that
was crazy that was great i mean you can
look at it yourself don't go on to
google trends
and put in for horizon forbidden west
and then put in eldon ring and you could
see for yourself where where the search
traffic was going
you know it's it's public information
only hit it with the public look at this
let me ask you this do you think the
disconnect when you see you know
comments like that like do you do you
think the disconnect is
looking at it the hardcore looking at it
through the hardcore lens and the the
older way of doing things whereas
everything was predicated on how much
something sold how many consoles how
much software so do you think it's
you know maybe as a hardcore we're just
looking at this older model and we don't
understand what this newer model is that
microsoft is trying to do it and if it
could be successful
it's a different it's not it's not
necessarily that it's a new model it's
just a different model
like sony has to have different
priorities because they can't afford to
build a cloud on par with microsoft they
just can't do it they have they'll have
to partner with someone else to do and i
think they use amazon web services right
now or something like that so they have
to think about their business in a
different way sony doesn't make
proprietary web tool uh development
tools which you know developers can buy
they don't have game stack and
you know they don't leverage
they don't use
their own games to showcase what their
technology does but i think sony could
make a load of money if they packaged up
the decimal engine and let all the
developers build on it you know
that could probably make money doing
that you know
um but microsoft's microsoft looks at
that because their mission statement is
empower others to do more right and they
think of it in like the context of
we want developers to be using our
servers we want gamers to be using our
services you know so they just have it
it's not that
and this is why i say they're not
competing it's because they're in a
different business model they're in a
different business
ultimately it's like that
when you're like a multi-trillion dollar
company are you really thinking about
the nickels and dimes of
competing in a tiny console wall
no you're thinking about how can we go
global how can we bring in more users
across the entire industry they think of
it as a as an
industry you know they want to be in
every part of the industry not just like
direct to consumer or whatever right so
they're just thinking about it in a
different kind of way
and um
you know
and they never back in the day i mean
they did it to some degree but never on
the sort of level they are now you know
with azure and stuff like that
and the fact that the xbox business is
anchored into azure
you know um just gives them a very
different set of priorities to
playstation i'm not like when when i say
xbox doesn't compete with playstation a
lot of people get all triggered and
upset and emotional about this because
it's they think it's like i'm saying oh
xbox has left sony in the dirt that's
not what i'm saying what i'm saying is
they they have a different
goal in mind they have a different
set of strategies to meet a different
goal you know
they just uh it's just different sort of
thing
like 10 cent 10 cent is the biggest
gaming company they do not make a
console
they don't make a console bars and
they're the biggest gaming company
tencent don't even put half their games
onto console
league of legends for xbox and
playstation bars
it's not there
because the console market is irrelevant
so you say that certain people are
fighting a fight that's not relevant
well let's let's let's let's my team
just destroyed up the team and then we
could worry about us being irrelevant
the whole order but what about this you
know jess
i want to give a little counterpoint and
i love what you're saying you're making
some fantastic points ma what about the
the mindset that you see sony
actually adopting azure the partnership
with microsoft them actually making
strides so as opposed to being i don't
you know tone deaf and not understanding
where the industry is going do you look
at that as them being late adopters or
you know that microsoft still is ahead
in this thing you don't look at that as
something as them trying to course
correct
uh i mean they're definitely trying to
course correct i mean look at look at
all the stuff with uh putting their
games on pc
and sort of trying to add add value to
their subscription services and stuff
like that
and they're definitely trying to think
about how can we sort of
meet microsoft on some of these value
propositions like xbox gamepads because
like i say the console business is
sony's entire business you know it's
they are a content company but the
content is their their entire business
basically right so um but it's different
from microsoft because they're all
they're a content and a services company
and their content business helps inform
their services business and their
services business helps inform their
content business so in a way microsoft's
almost selling to itself you know
and it's like the the technology that we
develop to sell to developers we can
also use this technology with our own
games you know right it goes around in a
cycle you know the
cloud is made of console hardware you
know for example yeah and we can bring
that audience to developers and we build
these apis so they can make cloud games
blah blah blah blah it's like it's this
whole industrial ecosystem that they're
building around their platform so
they're sort of they're sort of coming
at it from a completely different
perspective you know
valid points
the worry
if i was a business analyst and like you
know
uh
and i was like advising someone on you
know where to invest their money or what
the what the gaming industry could look
like in 10 years down the line it
wouldn't be microsoft that i'd be
worried about
frankly
yeah
i mean i'd be i'd be thinking more about
what what's sony going to do
when
console local hardware becomes
increasingly niche you know that's
what's the key finish
preaching the king's ears
yeah people don't want to accept that
console is niche right now it's already
niche okay
and what happens when they become even
more niche because people can get get
their games anywhere that they've got a
screen they can get it straight down to
their tv
they can get it on any device what
happens in that scenario
you know
so
it becomes um
the risk
proposition there becomes exponentially
higher potentially right because the
riskiest part of your business is making
expensive games that could flop
that's what i've been saying when that
they killed me when i say lord
consolidation because i'll be like if
you make a gay if you're a dev right now
a publisher and you make a game and it
flops with the millions of investment
you're you're out of here you're right
and to me that's why i see these
companies trying to make themselves sexy
for acquisition but continue to i i
completely agree with you there
yeah
it's um it's going to be an interest in
you know world and
you know sony's like it's not it's not
like until people in the chat are
already getting emotional
don't be like don't do this nobody's
yeah nobody's saying that sony's gonna
be doomed already nobody's gonna sony's
gonna be in trouble
yeah
kingdom be clear kingdom
it's 97 they're just on a different
level they're just like they're just
going to be on a different plane of of
business you know
so sony's going to be like doing their
thing selling selling consoles
putting their games on pc and pc is
going to become increasingly a big part
of their business they're going to
probably consolidate some of their um
you know some of their services into
subscriptions they bought crunchyroll
um
they got their music business
that's right see well microsoft
he's just sort of
you know the everything
i can see a future
yeah like you know
playstation games have become as
ubiquitous as xbox games are now like
you can play them anywhere you don't
need a playstation anymore oh my god
the king's getting excited this is good
let me get farther because i got to get
farther as far as i know fellow console
brethren you know likes to play things
the traditional way and you know what
this article that's come out you know
again by one person i'm saying the whole
forbes field is way better
you know that's just what article about
you know microsoft strategy being the
winning strategy long term you know
what's your thought process on this
funds coming from your perspective
uh it's already happening in terms of
you know
mass appeal when it comes to game pass
xcloud people are starting to
adopt it and and embrace it
we're seeing that and and this is coming
from a guy who
you know
last generation wasn't about you know
even digital gaming i remember so
so i i've seen the benefits of it and if
an old guy like me that was just
staunchly against just all digital
gaming
uh sees the light per se um
i i just think it's all about innovation
with technology man things move forward
um
if i could get an experience just as i
do on a native console
um with an application
why wouldn't i embrace it like
less clutter less things in the house to
to have to deal with you know and
hopefully less headache i don't know but
i just think that um you know
again it has to be
uh
one-to-one when it comes to native
consoles
and you know
whether you're streaming it or whatever
that the case may be
or if it's an application that you're
playing right off of it has to feel
exactly
like what i'm getting now the latency
wise all that stuff
um
but yeah i i i'm not one of those guys
who just uh doesn't want to embrace
innovation anymore i i look to the
future and i go yeah i can see this
happening and the microsoft is on the
right path i mean
they have started this um in the console
space anyway and and they have been at
the forefront
um
right now
playstation they're playing catch-up
they're trying and and for anybody to
say that they're not trying to do so
it's just being stupid um
no it's it's it's it's for real though
king um you know they see the future and
where things are going i mean that's why
they've started putting games on pc as
well that's why they're really embra
they've bought into the azure servers
that's why they're trying to get their
their uh service uh you know really
get going with this whole playstation
premium thing
um
i i i just i see all this being the
future of gaming and and and i'm okay
with that now i've i've kind of uh just
backed off that hole yeah i need my
physical games and i need my physical
consoles like
if if they can give me a great
experience
regardless of what i'm playing on an app
tv whatever it may be
i'm good with
it's just facts man it's it's what's
going on and i've personally seen the
difference in xcloud from when it
started in its infancy
that thing was not very good
and i and i had issues with it on wi-fi
but now on wi-fi it's exponentially
better than it was
i mean it's a hugely better than what it
was now it's not they're one-to-one with
native consoles right but it's closer
and the closer they get to that and when
they can perfect that
fonz is good with that also
wow
mods gaming polling in the building how
we feeling about this future man do we
think um
you know that according to forbes you
know one right or four like clarify that
um you know that this long-term strategy
of streaming and game pass
is the winning formula over their
console competitors
well
obviously i don't know per se but like
you know there might be on something
there i mean at the end of the day like
we we tend to look at things from our
own perspective right so we love to play
on our pcs consoles we will like having
you know like these you know having to
to to play with the hardware basically
and have that hardware and that kind of
stuff but like
when i look at my son he's nine years
old right um i had to force him to use a
console he all he wanted to do was to
play on on a mobile phone or tablet
right
um most of his friends
they they play on mobile right you know
some of them have consoles uh hardly
anyone plays on pc you know i'm talking
about like this demographic that eighth
demographic right yeah so
they are totally different to you know
and and they like different games now
like jazz actually made up
jazz actually made a very interesting
point you know um about the fact that
like console market is niche right and
and it is right like because
uh if you look at that it was an
interesting thing
there was an interesting thing about
fortnite right um they they started
adding those like spiderman god of war
and the kratos to for um
to fortnite um masterchief ended up
there as well and i i saw a joke
somewhere on which i think or whatever
right where um
a kid saw craters somewhere in in in the
actual god of war game and he's like oh
that's the guy from fortnite
yo isn't that crazy the generational gap
isn't that crazy exactly not the other
way around right so like it's like we
tend to well oh this is banger that game
sold like 10 million that's nothing in
comparison
so like
listen like i'm that old dude like i'm
42 years old i love my pcs consoles and
that kind of stuff and now and i'll
stick to it as long for as long as i
i'll be able to right
but like who knows what like fonz like
he said like he's embracing the all
these services and he he sees the value
there right so i have obviously i'm a
big fan of game pass and you know like i
enjoy all these of all these games there
and but the fact of the matter we don't
know where that's going to lead us to
right like in five six years from now
right
like this new generation like when i see
like my sons or like my
young neighbors around me right like
they are totally different to you know
you know to what
we are right it's a good point
and even and even the way we consume
stuff right like it's it's totally
different right so
no it's it's a good point i want to
bring the kids move i mean
is is there a disconnect are are we
the dinosaurs and the and the generation
is moving by and these young kids and
you know as king elegantly used to say
you know the the 10 million sold isn't
enough and you look at the live
engagement games i know hardcore gamers
don't want to hear this they don't want
to hear about you know that not the
bangers and we hear we look at the
roblox the fortnites and what's actually
in the top of engagement has it passed
us by kid it is is the new generation
winning this that leads towards this
this future where we actually
uh i i don't know but like any
generation that doesn't include like
consoles i'm not with oh you hold it on
let's go
i'm not gonna say that it's gonna like
i'm pretty sure it's the future
everything like you know however they
game in the future whether it be on a vr
headset or mobile phones um but i think
the the way i play games whether it be a
on a console
pc or whatever um is
once gaming is obsolete in that way i
i probably are you off the game oh you
watch the game
so xbox better have an option for you
with local gaming or else
yeah yeah i mean
you would have to really convince me
like once we get to like once another
you know alien ship comes and we get
this super crazy internet again where
everything just feels like local
super resolution whatever you know what
i mean then but at this point
now i like local hardware i still like
buying a box they already got me i'm not
buying musical games right that's as far
as i'm willing to go
i'm gonna be but it'll be actually like
a physical box let me ask you guys this
i was going to say smoove
but
my my point is because i'm with you man
i'm i'm all about that native box uh
because i want that
latest beta yeah he want that box data
all
if if in the future they can get it to
where it just it feels just like
i'm not going to say it but your native
box um
but anyway
don't you wouldn't you embrace it then
because i guess i would i'd embrace it
brace your native box bro yeah no wrong
with that box
i don't know
i don't know man it depends it depends
man hopefully this happens when you know
i'm incapable of playing video games at
that point i wouldn't care all right so
let me ask you guys
i don't know why i don't know why people
are so against it like that like let me
let me ask even if it's played the same
let me ask you this kid and and maybe
maybe
the way you run your household is how
you but i'm just curious you got kids
right
too much like how do they consume or is
it a situation where it's like you know
what you gonna play this console a
little know what they're like how are
they consuming games
i love my kids and my and my kids can be
can be weird sometimes i got mad at my
son right why what do you do
we're playing like
fall guys on um and he's playing on the
xbox one living room right and
and i'm like bro dude i was like just
play on the series that's just keep
getting disconnected i just put on the
series go ahead you can you can have it
go ahead and play it play it there it
was like trust me it's faster he cared
no i wouldn't play on the xbox one but
but why
and so right now there's literally
literally two
or stacked on top of it the xbox one s
is on the bottom the series s is on top
he'll turn on the series has to play
like
uh i i got him to play hello infinite
because i was like dude the controls are
mad delayed on xbox it just feels
different i don't know if it's because
it's 30 frames or something like that
but it feels way too different um and so
he'll play on that but to play like
something like
roblox or freaking wow
fall guys and stuff we were playing he
uh can you turn on xbox one for me i was
like it plays the cd
that generation don't care about that
man i'm telling you
when they update this thing because i
have a samsung tv in the living room i
was like okay well maybe i'll i can you
know i'll get rid of the boxes or
whatever yeah and hook them on to
because we all got game pass and whatnot
and maybe but i don't know if they'll
even embrace that i don't know i'm not
sure it depends like right now they
consume console and laptop that's how i
mean
no fair enough fair enough
it's very interesting to chart i want to
get attic real quick and then we get the
king and i don't know if he's back on it
he stepped away atticky back
yeah i'm here okay cool yeah man like
you know this this article like what
what do you think about the future is
this the the winning strategy so to
speak you know i mean i don't know
i do think that's the future eventually
i think it's
i think you'll start seeing remnants of
it i don't know if it'll be like in full
blown force in 10 years
um you know but sooner or later they're
going to get rid of the consoles
entirely and i think microsoft is
kind of setting themselves up for that
kind of world but
i wouldn't i wouldn't put sony out
like i i feel like
if anything sony has shown that they can
roll with the punches adaptability they
show an adaptability generation ps3 they
didn't show that type of adapter yeah
they they the fact that they made a
partnership with microsoft in general
shows that's because they're conforming
they're they're slowly changing
it's not just you're right it's about
adaptability but it's about conforming
to what's going on in the industry
i mean it's plain to see what uh what
sony's doing they're playing catch up so
yeah they could yeah anyway
enough
but that's the same thing though if they
have to adapt to it they're
acknowledging that that's where it's
going exactly right
no i feel you um king the floor is yours
you've been hearing all the bars you've
been wanting to hear smiling from ear to
ear
future consoles not existing
you know where you at with this article
once again we got mods on this we got we
got mods we've got minecraft about these
kids yeah yeah oh just they get me i
don't get me yeah
okay
because you you really you know bring up
the real you know you're like barry
bonds okay cool
yeah yeah yeah i'm like alex rodriguez
this is kind of crazy
that everybody is coming around to
embracing exactly what i've been saying
for a long time
the first one out the game is probably
playstation because the blows is just
going to keep coming pause it's going to
be absolutely ridiculous when the tweet
goes out yeah i ain't saying that's
happening with the playstation 6 era now
i think there will be a playstation 6.
you don't
i don't think there'll be a ps7 but i do
think there'll be a ps6 let me ask you a
question
fawns
how long does this generation last
at least eight years
eight years right at least yeah so then
you do believe that we're two years
behind because you know
constraints and lack of silicon kind of
yeah you know the pandemic you know so
we're we're like behind so it could be
extended for a little two more years
probably it could be a 10 year it could
be a 10-year thing
that's good ten years from now they they
see what you're saying
and i i want to cry he led the witness
yeah exactly this is what this is what i
do i'm a good lawyer uh
but i honestly
feel and
i think it's both of them but like jez
was saying i think microsoft sees the
value in the localized hardware just
because of
their streaming
that's that's the only thing
um
playstation won't need that if their
main commodity is the single player
games that these guys are going buck
bananas for right you guys are going
crazy for the bangers right
so
right so give me an exclusive phones and
it's not they're not going crazy for the
hardware because the hardware is being
outsold by little man right so for two
weeks
well hey it's about the bangers right so
everybody talk about if god of war
launches this year so if god of war
imagine if god of war launched
everywhere then jim will get the numbers
that he actually wants i just see
microsoft like you know just said like
all you guys said
is in a whole different game they're
playing a whole different game
from the other comp from the so-called
competition that's playing catch-up to
you guys eloquently saying that they're
playing catch-up anyway to microsoft
leading
in a whole different area and if you're
playing catch-up it's going to get to a
point where you can't catch up and you
have to switch gears and go and you set
adaptability right [ __ ]
so what happens when you say you know
what we got to cut the dead weight and
we can go with what's profitable i
believe that the game division is hugely
profitable i believe that the the
service plan that they're building
together right now will be hugely
immensely pros uh profitable
if it's on netflix or if it's on amazon
hey who knows but it will be someplace i
just feel that
this article eloquence
and illustrates all the stuff that i've
been saying
was so long and i do appreciate you guys
taking the time out to indulge my wild
[Music]
microsoft has definitely positioned
themselves from the hardware standpoint
future proofing from the networking
standpoint you know obviously the azure
backbone the infrastructure them getting
that everywhere that's critical to their
business model
and yeah you know i do think that there
is a disconnect with the hardcore gamer
and where the industry is going
and you know look a lot of these these
companies they do the analytics you know
i thought just made some fantastic
points about you know who are the actual
leaders as far as the revenue and stuff
like that and and you're seeing the 10
cents out there you know and being the
position they are without without
hardware right now we're still a ways
away in my opinion but to king's point
yes i do understand this generation may
go long we're talking about technologies
that you know like fsr2 and all sort of
stuff that can extend the generation and
make things great i also my predictions
probably we will get a console
generation refresh at some point you
know i feel that they looked at maybe
look at those analytics and said okay
there's people there's a market for
people who still want native hardware at
the highest fidelity on a local level
the cool thing about what microsoft's
doing i will say this is that even
though game pass and the streaming is
their future
i like that they have a model that's
flexible enough to still include
local hardware to still include the
ability to not alienate someone because
i think the mistake that stadia made is
they jumped too far ahead and said no
this is it this is the only way you
could consume our content and then that
puts people in business because let's be
honest there's still people that won't
be able to consume whether it be the
internet you live in a military base way
too soon right or your country's
infrastructure is not in proximity yet
to an azure server that you know that's
not that's not existed they got a
concert for you though
exactly and that's what i like to me the
mistakes
when i made like when when microsoft was
a little too aggressive with the even
though digital was right
with the xbox one they may was a little
bit too aggressive with forcing it right
so i think they learned from that and
now have this multi
you know tiered approach on how you can
get in because according to phil like
they've even said even though they want
this direction their end-all be-all
doesn't ride on game pass being
successful and and cloud stream like
they still have this multiple ways you
can get in their ecosystem and they can
still benefit combination of everything
that's right and i think that inclusive
thing kind of sits with the message even
with the games we want this variety of
games it's going to be in different
markets and everything like that so it
all fits i will say to sonido i think
the difference i know you don't give
enough credit king but i think the
difference is
this is not a stubborn
ps3 era type sony
ps3 era type sony's like nope this is
the way we're doing it 600 console get
down lay down and whatever and i think
the fact that they're like wait a minute
we can make a somewhat of a competitor
to game pass whether it be the ps
premium and we have our different tiers
we can somewhat we're not going to do
day and date initially but maybe we put
dip our toe in with these multi-player
these live service games and some games
will be day and date right then we see
in the pc implement a lot of people
weren't ready for that they fought us at
rp we've said multiple times it's
happening shout out to rand outdoor just
caught in some amazing teammate you know
who got killed on here saying yo these
games are going to come god of war all
that stuff that people fought and i
think that's what's going on here
there's a lot of i would say antiquated
thing but of the old way of doing things
is the only way to be successful and i
think we are seeing a change in regard
the last point i say which kid's move
and mods brought out is i think that i
think bro we the minority we we are the
hardest of the hardcore
but unfortunately if you look at the top
10
mpd look at the top 10
games played a lot of the time even if
the games we like i think el dorado may
be the exception this year that has
consistently stayed where it's at it's
generally not the games that the
hardcore are playing no it's not it's
the roblox the minecrafts you know what
i'm saying
the cards the fortnites you know what
i'm saying like those are the games that
are you know you see the four guys up
there
and that's what i think we have to be
cognizant of i think that's where jess
also made a fantastic point where
it hurts to say but console is niche
like it does seem weird to even say that
right
i think we're just in that we're in an
inflection point and we have to really
be cognizant of what's happening around
us and i'm not one of them old dudes
where it's just like i'm just going to
just you know keep throwing out the
crowd you know throw it at the cloud
like never never it could happen we just
got to see if the technology advances to
where it is
what you said about like
um
there being
um
different ways of doing things i mean
this is this is a point phil always
mentions in his in his high level
interviews with like the mainstream
media he talks about xbox having a
plurality of business models he talks
about having a plurality of business
models for developers not every game
needs to be fortnight to be successful
and critically
not every developer wants to make
fortnite reach you know it's and square
enix like very famously tried to force
crystal dynamics to make them a service
game
and then they had to concede crystal
dynamics just they weren't set up for it
they were basically given this project
and told okay make this make this
destiny somehow
and they didn't have the dna to do it
whether they anthem another example
anthem good point exactly what's funny
is the biggest the biggest l's we've
seen in the industry come from forest
creativity
yeah jeff exactly so you know and we've
seen indie developers make millions and
millions of dollars you know not
billions of dollars but they've made
millions of dollars and
they've had a lot of success building
businesses that are just you know
smaller it's just
the social media encourages like binary
thinking where it's like everything has
to be one one way has to be the other
one
but is not it's not just it's just not
how reality works in reality there's
always going to be in there's always
going to be developers who are sort of
our age who want to make games that
people our age want to play
you know and then they'll be big
publishers who they'll chase the trends
and they'll try and make every game
about royale while they try desperately
to to to attach that younger audience
who frankly have less money to spend
than we do
so
while while they went all in trying to
cater to these trends a lot of these
companies like ea they went balls to the
wall chasing trends ignoring their core
audience
and now they're having to course correct
again and be like oh here's a dead space
remake please don't hate her
[Laughter]
it's
it's this sort of binary thinking which
is like a trap you know it's like well
all the kids they all play fortnite and
road blocks now that's all they want to
play which means you know we can't have
triple a single player games anymore but
that is just not right you know if
there's if there's people there want to
make a triple a single player game and
there's enough people there's still an
audience to make those games they'll
still get made you know yes and um
it's just the industry's evolving to
accommodate different kinds of audiences
in like you know
um it's the industry's maturing and it's
changing
and um
some people have you know their fear
change and they aren't they can only
think in like one ways right way in
every room that was me that was me yeah
i was there too i was just like how are
they gonna survive i mean look
look at vinyl you know look at vinyl
records vinyl records are now out
selling cds because there's enough
people who are our age and older who are
nostalgic for that [ __ ] and you've got
you've got companies like limited run
games we're making collectors editions
for direct digital games because there's
enough of an audience there
and they're happy to not be a billion
dollar corporation they're just
passionate about this and they want to
do it and make some money as well like
there doesn't have to be one way all the
highway you know
mods and attic and then we wrap up
yeah i just wanted to add something
because it's always nice to listen to
clever people and something i just met
that that made me to realize something
um
the technology that microsoft actually
offers is uh kind of very cool for
developers as well because like you know
if you go back like 10 15 years back
like you know you've had all these kind
of different well pcs consoles like each
had to
uh if you uh if you were like a
multi-platform um developer you had to
like make like different versions of the
game for different hardware but now with
all these services and that kind of
stuff and cloud
um
and you know like
and the xbox actually you just make one
game right and like obviously now like
microsoft is trying to streamline
the porting from xbox to pc actually
they kind of like trying to make it like
as one right
and so like developer would just make a
game for pc or xbox same difference
and that game would work on uh
pc xbox and all these cloud devices
uh basically expanding the the reach of
the game right
so and instead of like porting and this
is like an and it's an interesting thing
as well like when playstation you know
some of the places you guys are getting
angry pictures oh i won't be able to
play this or that game anymore right
well not really
because i'm sure you've got a laptop
you're sure you've got like um a mobile
device careful mods they don't like that
talk like what i don't like
on a console and they don't want no one
else having that game
i don't care the fact of the matter is
that like
oh i can't play it i can't because well
we'll play it on your something tv play
it on your
um
laptop like you don't you you actually
all you need for game streaming all you
need a 300 laptop you know and uh and a
controller you probably will be able to
actually use a playstation controller
with it right about you pay for them off
so it's it's totally different and i
know that some people don't like it well
but it is what it is right it's just
like different talk
no i feel you know i'm just i'm being
silly but literally that's what they say
they don't want
they want their ecosystem not everybody
but there's a certain contingent that
want to play their games playstation
games only on their platform and they
get a platform for them it's called the
play store
and they don't like jim ryan and they
don't like this vision you know what jim
ryan's vision though is is one of a
western
vision if you really think about this
remember that playstation years ago
uh they decided that they were going to
focus the playstation market within the
western division because when it comes
to consoles yes they're niche but the
biggest markets are in the western world
um
over there in japan it's all about
mobile gaming and stuff so playstation
is heavily focused on the western uh
division and and i think like when it
when it comes to their games and stuff
they cater
uh their exclusives and everything most
of their games cater to the western
world
and i i think they that will also uh
follow into you know the trends and
everything and where it's moving
within the western world do you know
what i was saying so your game passes
your everything that's changing here
is where they're going to align with
where they're going to go in the future
and i know some playstation playstation
fans don't want to hear that but that's
just the reality they themselves did
this years ago they decided hey the
western market is it for us yeah they
they did a shift let's get out of can we
get about it what you thought man yeah
one more point you want to jump in i
mean at the end of the day
you know people are going to go where
the money is
uh
a lot of people try to do the fortnight
thing the problem when you try to make
roblox fortnite stuff you try to get
that that real world money is you don't
have a product worth that real real
money you're trying to force the product
and i feel like that's when you see the
anthems
uh you know you you see all these
studios the marvel uh the marvel
avengers games like
people want the destiny the gta 5 money
but they don't want to put in that
bungee and and rock star work right yeah
and that that's why you know you see a
lot of companies fail in certain aspects
because they're not they're they're
trying to shortcut their weight into
that kind of money when it doesn't work
back then right you know there's a
reason these studios are able to do what
they do is because they put a lot of
work defining their craft finding out
what works what doesn't work and that's
why i'm kind of glad that the the
market's kind of correcting itself we've
seen the dead space remakes because ea
could have easily went back to the
drawing board said
all right let's try it again without
like oh god we dropped we messed up on
anthem all right you go go back and make
that uh make a dragon age yeah we need
that we need that mass effect too get
that to them
they'll leave us a little dead space i
know we shut that studio down have them
remake it have the remake that'll keep
us off the off of us
it's just like
i do agree that
the casual market runs and it's it's ran
the market for for for generations
but
i appreciate
that places like ea and stuff
they've seen
them chasing that bag has hurt their
company more than helping it
not every company can come out with a
minecraft with a fortnight well for
roadblocks
yeah yeah and you you see these
companies that have tried that for
all of our xbox one generation keep in
mind some of these people almost every
publisher tried to throw out that give
me money game you had uh square enix
dude with the marvel avengers
you had um
anthem with bioware
and so ea uh square enix you can try
like nine of them yeah catch it if
people try to catch a wave there's no
doubt there's no doubt so you know but
but now you're starting to see ubisoft
you know talking about doing uh they did
the the phoenix rising game that was
not standard to their type of games
they're talking about brainy um
uh what's it called uh
game with the the green
goggles splinter cell they're talking
about breeding split is so bad you know
you see ea
revisiting uh dead space now you see ea
revisiting dragon age like you see ea
revisiting mass effect which is stuff
that if anthem would have popped off
they never would have done right they
would have stuck with that so it's just
like it's give and take and i feel like
a lot of publishers they want that easy
money but when it blows up when they
face they want to blame us for it why do
you buy a game make better games and
people will buy them yeah look there's a
place for everything you know and i
think from a
development standpoint you definitely
still need balance and i think i think
the indie scene doesn't get enough
credit and i think xbox doesn't get
enough credit for cultivating the indie
scene in the way that they have as i
think a lot of the innovation that
ultimately that i want sometimes comes
from that and then the big aaa you know
they will then copy and say okay that's
the way that we can invest it because i
think people are afraid of the risk and
bombing on the risk so and yeah
and then you can look at it from a
standpoint that
services like game pass make it easier
to continue making those classic games
because you're you because they're
pretty much
monetizing all of the games they're not
just trying to do one at a time
obviously you got to see these trying to
do the cosmetic and i think they're
trying to monetize a lot of live
services going to game pass but you got
you got games like a valve which to my
knowledge doesn't have any type of micro
transactions fable which my knowledge
obviously we don't know too much about
these games but
to to
as of right now they haven't really said
that they have any type of micro
transactions they're throw they're
making the games that everyone wants but
they're putting in a subscription
service to constantly get that revenue
knowing they're still going to sell on
pc no they're still going to make deals
with like epic to get them on there
exclusively they're still going to make
enough money to justify the pc versions
but the description is going to justify
continuously to making diverse content
to make a different type of genre
content that you wouldn't necessarily
seem without something like game pass
because they wouldn't have that nate
that safety net at the moment yeah the
stability disability no i hear your
point man fantastic it's an interesting
article i love this type of talk great
stuff from the panel king shout out to
you with the thought provoking
discussion that went your way
but uh yo let's get up out of here
before we uh you want to clear up these
super chats i'll do the outros or
whatever yeah you know what i'm saying
but um yeah man i want to shout out to
the legendary chess caught in windows
central xbox two rocked with us the
whole way salute to your badge you could
make your brother definitely want to
catch up with you where can the fine
people find you what you got going on
man
hey find me on twitter jess corden and
of course on the xbox two podcasts the
xbox two
podcasts you could say it's your podcast
you you just
do it with some other guys
every time every time someone cites you
guys podcasts
say it's my podcast my my you know the
robin in the sidecar
shout out to randall red i love you
brother you know i'm messing with you i
love that joke but shout out to the
shout out to the team
uh i could do that right yeah the whole
week guys holy [ __ ]
yeah i'm just uh
i'm on windowscentral.com writing random
articles and stuff
yeah love what you do man
i'm sorry i was like no all good but i
love what you're doing love love the the
integrity with the journalism love the
courageousness with the journalists a
lot of times you put yourself out there
and are critical with microsoft when you
need me and i love that balance so
salute to you good friend to the realm
my god just caught it and of course
returning who we have not seen in a
while you know what i'm saying two
people we haven't seen it well but i'll
start with one first let me find zorelli
gaming man i'm so glad to see your face
you know it's been a minute we know you
had a lot of things going on and um it
is so good to hear you and see you
talking games see that smile the laugh
and the classic fonz isms you know what
i'm saying in the realm what's going on
with you when can the five people find
you when i heard you might be coming
back
yes so um i'm going to start content
creating again
very soon um next sunday i will be back
with season two of my games talk live
and i will have none other than the ash
and luca yeah so that should be a great
time to come out 2 p.m
pacific time
if you will and
have a great time with me and luca we're
going to be talking about her of course
i'd like to interview my guests
especially the first time get to know
them a little bit better if you don't
know already but i'm sure you'll find
out things you probably didn't know
um and we're going to have a good time
there talking about games having fun and
of course the five questions uh
and uh we're going to have that game
show return that gay show music brother
love it
um yeah so catch me there on fonzarelli
gaming so absolutely i appreciate
everybody in the chat appreciate all of
you you know i love you guys you're my
brothers
uh but yeah thank you everybody for uh
thanks for the invite kyle well no doubt
you know i'm glad you're accepted too
and of course my technical brother lord
mods gaming of the mods gaming youtube
channel always breaking and educating us
plebs here or what's going on with this
tech salute to you brother good to see
you again long time haven't had jonah
you've been rocking with us from the
beginning too man always good to hear
from you what you have going on where
can i find people find you
well you can find me on twitter you can
find me on the on youtube uh mods gaming
you know okay i'm usually talking about
some
weird text stuff and some other weird
stuff you know so you know
you never know you may like it
um so
thanks for the invite really enjoy the
uh the conversations uh the the panel i
love everyone around over here so like
follow you all guys watch your content
you know that's what it's all about like
xbox community is kind of cool around
here so i like it it's like you know
yeah i love it so anyway so great
there's some weirdos out there but we
don't talk about that
yeah yeah so thanks thanks thanks again
for the invite and
much love mods gamer and of course the
best spot pulling in
saying yo
what's going on i heard there's
something some talk going on i need to
know what's up he came to the rescue
held us down just in case
much love kid smoove the best spot
playing at xbox finalists where can you
find people finding what you going on
yeah man yeah i've been trying to get
some videos out trying to get into a
rhythm um to you know get some content
out but you can find me on youtube.com
slash kidsmove uh twitter um they said i
got some videos coming
um some more uh modern monitor reviews
coming um yeah so i got a new one so
we're gonna be uh talking about that
smooth is actually making some technical
weird videos
my knowledge is extremely limited so
it's literally you know my minor reviews
is for casuals only what do you want to
hear that's it i don't care about the
animal that's the majority of people
looking at the videos
um yeah my wife came home the first
thing she said was why you got that [ __ ]
out
off everything in the store that's
absolutely that's a kid's move original
no but it was the coolest thing i picked
out from this side
shout out to the shirt blocking it no
doubt absolutely look
he came in the door he was like oh god
i told you about that shirt kid
salute to the best but i salute the kids
move the legend you already know attic
you know what i'm saying the homies
what's going on man we can find people
find you what you got going on you want
me to do you want me to do the super
chats and we'll do ours after yeah let's
do that and then let's let people loose
they gotta go yeah yeah we're hauling
people hostages
this is my pee break i've been holding
it
no just just go just go i'll read the
super chats while you use the bathroom
all right no doubt but look everybody be
right back and again if anybody has to
leave what you got to do and uh we're
going we're going to support the people
and read these super chats i just want
to thank everybody for showing up if
y'all do gotta run i suggest y'all run
now
we gotta catch it up battle yeah now
that we're kicking you out
i'm kicking you out get out of here last
sunday
cause it's light here but yes
thank you brother
thank you
flame i'm taking the earphones with me
yes
[Laughter]
all right so let me go ahead and still
have a native box oh
that was good all right so we have a
members chat for 25 months from scrub
nurse
glad to catch you guys love king wild in
and out glad to see the panel and
definitely glad to see fawns put the
christ in the chat on garden then
blessing we got a five dollars from
stitch mix
skills eight uh elton ring is poorly
optimized on all platforms running on
subpar 60.
i was just saying uh fsr could help it
fix it but thanks for dissing a fellow
xbox gamer i have no clue maybe i just
you know he did but i i don't worry
about it guys i love you i was just
messing with you man
got a fight that's when he was like the
the ttl joke
uh
i gotta file a screenshot from dj orris
sunday night hockey hashtag leg day
hashtag hey bestie iop fall guys day
got a five dollar super chat from uh
lucious augustus if god of war gets a uh
a nod and comes out on 11 11 i'm coming
for all the journalists that say they
didn't have time for forza horizon five
got a two dollar shooter from tx uh uh
thx one one three eight thanks one one
three eight i guess kingly say that
november five is the cut off for the
goat
so it had to come out before november
fifth
i don't know if that's happening you
gotta for ten outstretch from parky
shanee the last of us remake
is september
pre-remake
it's september the 15th
uh september
uh
and then we got for spoken in october
called october 28th november worked for
ragnarok but would sony risk releasing
it past the keely cutoff don't they need
big games for the for next year
that is interesting would he
willingly sacrifice
a because here's the thing if they
release god of war
past
the threshold for this year
first off it's got the fact that it was
at the beginning of the year rather than
the light of the year or the middle of
the year and they got to compete with
breath of the wild too
so i kind of feel like they're going to
try to push it before that cut-off date
because they know they love those games
too
you get what i'm saying
i don't i think that comes out all i'm
saying is is
would they be willing to to potentially
sacrifice the game of the year icon when
they could easily get it this year if
they if
they well i mean if they fought for i
don't know if they'd be able to ring i
don't think they would
we got
what really matters is how god over
going to get bodied by spendaments
if it tries to if it tries to launch in
november oh on god in them oh god of
numbers
the
exact same person five dollars from
donald taku
now i'm just kidding ragnarok will be
the third best game of the year behind
xenoblade three and now
he's talking that xenoblade he also got
a two dollar super chat from donald
tucker god of war ragnarok a 91 but
breath of the wild to the 92 back to
back oh okay back to back okay got a
five dollar super from j1 greetings to
all i like xbox strategy of getting more
people in game pass with a diverse
section such as games like uh narcica
and
uh benefit fox benedict fox
yeah yeah that's why i played it before
though mm-hmm pc then we got uh a
five-hour superstar from dollar to taco
10 years from now
that 5g and starlink is everywhere you
can get stable internet everywhere in
the world cloud gaming will completely
take over local okay five years and
that's the end of your playstation 6.
bush's necromancer
zolly
with the 10 super chat great show guys
thanks for the episode effort expertise
and entertainment that having everyone
in one show makes it provides everyone
great information and fun call keep
pushing that powder welcome
powder go to advanced gg.com go get that
cold iron lord on the chicken keep in
mind i didn't read the uh what super
chats we read on um
what's his name uh the the journalist
that was here tommy edison
yeah we read those
all right then we got a a title spread
from necroman no i just read that we got
a five dollar super chat from
uh donataku and that's not even talking
about the improvements as zero will make
in that time look at where xcloud was
two years ago till now
definitely then we got a 20 superchat
from parky chinese he pointed out tech
make it uh uh tech will make it on
consoles isn't needed he's right the tv
will be good enough to run games
natively mobile console won't matter for
harcourt pc for general it will be the
tv enhanced by xcloud i agree a sooner
or later uh those kind of programs are
going to replace it
because sooner or later they're going to
be able to tackle the
uh the you know the one for one thing
yeah the latency five dollar scoop chat
from gaming forte
there from your favorite gamestop
manager thanks for the extremely long
podcast my day's almost over and as
always
hey booboo hey kid
hey forte
he's back
then we got a five dollar super trap
from flame
sorry dawn but
triangle strategy eldon ring xenoblade
three then god will wreck rock bend your
knee to the real game of the year you
know i will say
triangle strategy is a really really
good game yeah i'll say that
then we got a two dollar super chat from
lord metro
a link to the past is the best zelda
game
period i don't know man i'll have to
probably give that to the ocarina of
time still to this day
to this day
well
it's over just like the playstation
you're ridiculous anyway look man
fantasy show slash everybody that pulled
up attic what you got going on man you
had a fantastic thing with um obsidian's
senior narrative and yeah so definitely
if you guys haven't watched it it's on
the channel it's uh my last week's attic
show i did get a couple dms uh so i will
be separating those two okay uh i gotta
do different artwork because i need a
new logo
so keep keep in mind and look for that
um i will be
live streaming cuphead when it comes out
on the 30th it'll probably be on this
channel when is
the 30th this
it's usually the same day in state of
play you said i mean cuphead would get
released
yeah oh okay the dlc uh also
i will be finishing the cory i don't
know if it will be with my girl or not
because
i got to get that game done i can't keep
waiting on people's schedule to sync up
i got to get that game done but uh i
appreciate uh i don't know if i'll i
think at this point i'm so close i might
as well just finish streaming it i might
just finish it tomorrow streaming it but
i appreciate every couple three we had
up to i think it was almost 900 people
in here
you know we have
469 likes let's go ahead you know we
still got 590 people tell me we can't
get that above 500 before the end of the
show man let's get that up above 500
before the end of the show and
king will do backflips in his house
flipping my whole life
no i was gonna say we we we we do have a
couple things coming here in the in the
in the future
i know that we've been saying we'll do
live streams but like here's the thing
you guys don't realize
um
all of us have crazy schedules and it's
almost impossible to find like a
designated day that works best for
everyone yeah uh we won't have a show
next week uh but i am gonna talk to king
to see if he wants to do some like live
stream for you guys next week yeah you
know maybe we'll do some kind community
day i don't know but i'm not i'm not
promising anything because pretty much
me and king will be the only ones in
town everyone else is out of town
i thought it might be my birthday
weekend i'm out of town
okay
no we ain't
unless i do something with the community
will probably not be doing that next
week but but you know we added we could
do something that's what i was going to
tell you we could pre-record whatever
we're going to do we'll talk about it
but we're going to get y'all something
we going even if it's down to men at it
you know with our elbows you know how we
do man i didn't go talk we attack these
rough hard games in these streets really
you do and i'll be in the background
cheering them on with the pom-poms
but we outside
that's my guy we have something that's
ridiculous okay but uh i appreciate
everyone coming through yeah it's a
little king we're gonna find people find
you what you got going on sir okay so
apparently people don't know they can
find me on xbox with king david otw like
it is on my twitter so if you see my
twitter right that's the same exact
thing king david otw and it doesn't mean
on the way it means of the world so stop
telling me yo king you're on the way
stop it's not funny um
on
my playstation whenever i do decide to
log in and fix it with these guys yo
first of all why i called playstation at
two o'clock in the afternoon they said
call us back at regular business
i was mad as hell because i was trying
to you know log into my playstation
which they have uh banned me from
beyonce i don't know
yeah right but my um my name is xbox 360
level one over there so uh shout out to
your boy it i will never give out my
switch social security number that's
nothing to happen
lords of gaming dotnet
there's a new um article up i just
finished watching solves too yeah last
minute yeah i watched the lord's minute
with soft that that was pretty good that
was pretty dope but i can see how the
day segment goes along it's ridiculous
um but uh tune in to mine
we talked about obi-wan and series and
the uh um
the final episode which is really good
we're going to start talking about miss
marvel next week and then that's going
to roll into thor love and um thunder
because i think that's going to be
really good with christian bale talking
about stuff listen guys we don't talk
only video games combat talk with the
king is coming back well with stuff like
that and king of the statues that stuff
is being worked on show me your build is
coming yeah that stuff is coming that
t-shirt is coming
we're going to be doing a whole lot more
new t-shirts and we're gonna be working
on our tears i want to engage with the
community at a different level you know
um
as far as these games go i was playing
fallout uh four guys the other day and
it was pretty good um you know mod said
something about fallout 76 uh cox said
uh some other stuff about uh renting
servers so
how dope would it be if we can get a
game that we can rent the server and we
can have a hundred of
people there and we can play you know
pub g or whatever the hell like what
else we want to play with the lords or
whatever um i think that'd be really
dope and i think you guys would really
appreciate that because i really
appreciate it with you guys so we can
bond with you guys on on a deeper gamer
level uh remember guys um
it's not where you play is how you play
and please play clean you know with your
friends you know because
they're gamers you know even though i
joke about these playstation guys and i
joke around i'm a playstation guy i'm an
owner right but it's all jokes it's all
light-hearted jokes but i do
mean that there's no playstation 6
coming in say cog a crack a croc with a
crown emote win
no
yo i'm going to do that it's going to be
crocs
it's going to be killer croc and it's
going to be dope i'm gonna have a yeah
thank you thank you i appreciate that
anyway let me hit graphic
[Laughter]
show your bill coming soon
you're ridiculous anyway let's look at
the rub everybody pulled up a lot of fun
like i said next week as addict said
lords will be offered figured out what
we will give you guys i know i will be
in chicago and i know um asob is still
on vacation you know what i mean so but
we will figure out to give you something
but i appreciate everybody coming
through hit that like button a lot of
good content again salute to everybody
that you saw up in here subscribe to the
channels support what they're doing as
well fawns jazz mods kid everybody man
salute but that's all i got out of you
anything else before we get up out of
here
no that that's about all all right it's
tuesday see you there
no doubt everybody y'all enjoy your
weekend have a good one we're out of
here please watch out don't blow up your
fingers them firecrackers
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh